coming up later in machine learning
street talk professor yan lacoon
the godfather of deep learning
there's been a lot of people
uh who who have been sort of
saying there is a limitation to deep
learning let's say or machine learning
more generally
because it's obvious that those things
basically do curve fitting and that only
works for interpolation and not for
extrapolation
and that kind of
dismissal always sounded wrong to me
would this qualitative difference be in
the form of
uh fundamentally different things from
deep learning you know things that are
you know like discrete symbolic
reasoning or or things of that type and
to that my answer is clearly no i do not
believe that's the case
that's a limitation of supervised
learning it has absolutely nothing to do
with deep learning
computing on things okay and i put a
step right there we also had a
fascinating conversation with randall
bellistrio
from meta ai research
so i think it's two different things to
be able to interpolate or move on your
manifold and being in the interpolation
regime from your training set
so is this similar to interpolation
well i mean all of machine learning is
similar to interpolation if you want
right
when you train a linear regression on
scalar values you're training a model
right you're giving a bunch of pairs x
and y
you're asking what are the best values
of a and b for y equals ax plus b that
minimizes the squared error of the
prediction of a line to all of the
points right that's linear regression
that's interpolation
all of machine learning is interpolation
in a high-dimensional space there is
essentially no such thing as
interpolation everything is
extrapolation so imagine you are in in a
space of images right so you have color
images 56 by 256 so 200 000 dimensional
input space even if you have a million
samples you're only covering a tiny
portion of the dimensions
of that space right those images are in
a tiny sliver
of of surface among the the space of all
possible combinations of values of
pixels
so when you show the system a new image
it's very unlikely that this image is a
linear combination of previous images
what you're doing is extrapolation not
interpolation okay and in how dimension
all of missionaries is extrapolation
which is why it's hard now that was a
clip that went out on the chalet show
and i think i understand now what lacoon
meant he's saying that our intuition of
interpolation is only correct in a very
low number of dimensions it's a
mathematical impossibility to have
statistical generalization in high
dimensions so he's not saying that
neural networks are really extrapolating
in the sense of continuing the pattern
he's saying our definition of
extrapolation the convex whole
membership is broken machine learning
does not and will never work in high
dimensions that's why we've invented so
many tricks to reduce the statistical
and approximation complexity of problems
just like we do in computer science of
the computational complexity of
algorithms lacoon is not saying that
deep learning models are clairvoyant
yan lacoon thinks that it's species to
say that neural network models are
interpolating because in high dimensions
everything
is extrapolation
oh boy
we started thinking about making this
show many months ago when randall
bellistrio and jerome pogente and
yanderkoon first released their paper
learning in high dimensions
always amounts to extrapolation and
it feels like a lot has happened since
then i mean they do say the mark of an
educated mind is being able to change
your opinion
in light of new evidence
where we are now compared to where we
were then i mean let's just say i feel
like i'm standing on the surface of
pluto
um i was initially quite skeptical of
this paper and i was trying to pick it
apart and now
it feels like we've done 180 degrees not
only on on the way we think about the
paper but how we think about neural
networks in general and we really want
to try and impart some of that knowledge
with you today in the introduction which
might be quite ambitious so please bear
with us but you know generally speaking
the structure of the show today it's
going to be a big show it's going to be
a big show use the table of contents
um skip around a bit
but there's an intro there's a com you
know where we talk about this blind view
or this boundary view of neural networks
which i think is very interesting
there's a conversation with yandere
the godfather of deep learning and um we
also speak with randall bellastrio who
released this beautiful paper about
thinking about neural networks in this
new way and we have a debrief as well so
yeah i've not edited the show yet but
it's going to be about three hours
anyway
the show must go on so um as i was
saying
particularly speaking with randall was a
revelation i originally thought that the
authors were saying that people
shouldn't think of neural networks as
interpolators because they thought
neural networks were doing something
even more sophisticated but what i came
to realize at least in randall's case is
he's even more cynical about the
behavior of neural networks than gary
marcus he doesn't think that they're
fitting curves at all
reading randall's recent spline theory
of deep learning paper has completely
changed the way that i think about their
behavior
so um
his view basically is that neural
networks recursively chop up the input
space
um into these little convex cells
or polyhedra conceptually similar to
decision trees but one where the regions
in the layer can share information which
means that different faces of these
polyhedra will correspond to different
hyperplanes
set down by different neurons in the
neural network of course ones which are
topologically addressable from that
location so to me like this ends the
notion that these neural networks are
learning smooth data manifolds or
performing smooth geometric
transformations in the generative
setting which i used to think of as
being a kind of diffiomorphism um it
also gave me the realization that at
least in inference each input prediction
is representable with a single linear
affine transformation which leads
directly to the next realization which
is that the latent space is not
homogeneous it's potentially a different
space for every single input example i
just didn't realize that before you know
suddenly a lot of the magic of deep
learning has vanished and i see them in
the same light as things like decision
trees and svms and classical machine
learning i mean probably because i
understood those things very deeply
so yeah neural networks have lost a
little bit of their mystery but i think
it's a good thing
reminds me a little bit of this parable
of the the blind men and the elephant
where let's say you've got four blind
men around an elephant
one's got his arm around the trunk
oh it feels like a snake
one's one's feeling the tail or it looks
like a rope or it feels like a rope um
one's on the side or it feels like a
wall and it's very similar situation
with neural networks that you know the
experience of these blind men um it's
it's all the truth but it's not the
complete truth uh we're all just trying
to understand this thing from different
angles now anyway
the two key challenges in machine
learning
are one the curse of dimensionality and
there's a corollary of that knowing what
to ignore in the input space because it
blows up exponentially with the
dimensions
and two the extrapolation problem what
happens when you extrapolate outside of
the trading data
and why does this notion of
extrapolation even matter
well put simply it matters because of
the implications it has for
generalization in deep learning
now why do deep learning models work at
all
well i think there's an incredible
amount of engineering which goes into
these state-of-the-art machine learning
models which makes them work very well
on specific tasks
but
it's easy to deceive yourself with
neural networks
literally everything about your training
process and predictive architecture
could be leaking domain specific
information into your model neural
networks are not really blank slate
models like we've been led to believe a
lot of human crafted domain knowledge
goes into these models
and by the way this is why francois
schwarle i mean he talks about this
notion of developer aware generalization
which is being able to generalize to
tasks which the developer of the system
didn't know about at the time
now weights and biases is the developer
first mlops platform build better models
faster with experiment tracking data set
versioning and model management it
provides a platform and a set of tools
which you can use for the entire life
cycle of your machine learning process
every team has a reliable system of
record for their engineering system
right whether it's azure devops for
software engineering or confluence for
team wikis
weights and biases is your system of
record for machine learning now for your
quick link and to help out the podcast
head over to 1db dot me forward slash
mlst
i'm extremely proud actually that we've
been sponsored by weights and biases
i've been a huge fan of what they've
been doing since the very beginning and
also i've been a part of their community
forum they are the one company who in my
opinion has totally changed the game
around what is the highly nuanced
process and the kind of
multi-disciplinary team actions that are
required to get machine learning models
safely into production i've been a chief
data scientist for a major corporation
for the last 18 months or so and i've
always been a big believer in
introducing engineering rigor to machine
learning and data science engineering
fundamentals are so important when you
bring machine learning systems to
production as is helping data scientists
to become first-class citizens in the
entire life cycle of model development
and deployment it's almost a shame that
mlst has become quite science orientated
because in my day job i'm an engineer
first i would love to make more content
about this stuff anyway weights and
biases helps you go faster it makes your
team more resilient by increasing your
knowledge sharing it helps you build
models which not only have better
predictive performance but are more safe
and secure weights and biases gives you
better management information allowing
your company to make better decisions
and build data products with greater
transparency than ever before and
critically because weights and biases
orchestrates the entire machine learning
process your models are reproducible and
important decisions are immortalized
this fine level of control lets you set
guard rails where you need to and reduce
friction wherever possible
i've designed many ml devops systems
over the years including when i worked
at microsoft the technology has really
come of age now and i think you should
be using a platform like weights and
biases to help you train your machine
learning models and to get them into
production
reproducibility has always been one of
the biggest problems in machine learning
and the reason for that is that these
systems are quite brittle frankly their
runtime characteristics depend strongly
on the vagaries of the training regime
the choice of hyper parameters even the
hardware that they were trained on you
know you always get into this syndrome
where it works on my machine but i can't
put it into production because i've got
no idea how to recreate this thing
somewhere else i work in a highly
regulated industry and we often need to
wind the clock back to try and
understand how a model was created which
decisions were made and possibly go back
later to reason about a model's behavior
this is precisely what weights and
biases does now it's completely free for
academics and it's simple to get started
you just have to add a few lines of code
so what are you waiting for remember to
click on our special link because it
helps us out that's 1db dot me forward
slash mlst we are so grateful for the
sponsorship from weights and biases and
also feel free to get in touch with us
if you're interested in sponsoring the
show it'll help us scale up the
operation a little bit because at the
moment i'm doing all the editing and it
takes a lot of time anyway thank you
very much
randall's other recent work demonstrates
that a large class of neural networks
including cnns resnets rnns and beyond
those that use piecewise linear
activation functions like relu
can be entirely rewritten as
compositions of linear functions
arranged in polyhedra or cells in the
input space
it's a high resolution slice and dice
into linear forms like a fruit ninja set
loose on a marching cubes algorithm such
as k-means clustering matched filter
banks and vector quantization
which in plain english means locality
sensitive clustering
it also provides new insight into the
functioning of neural networks
themselves
for example with this view what a neural
network is doing is performing an input
sensitive lookup
for a matching filter
and then computing a simple inner
product between that filter and the
input signal
if that doesn't shed light on francois
chile's characterization of neural
networks as locally sensitive hash
tables
then i don't know what will
another cool thing to come out of
randall's work was a geometrically
principled way of devising
regularization penalty terms
which can improve neural network
performance by
orthogonalizing the placement of those
latent hyperplane boundaries to increase
their representational power
in short looking at neural networks
through this piecewise linear
kaleidoscope if you will
is opening new avenues of technical
understanding and exploration
now we spoke with yannick about this as
well
and he commented that he had looked into
these polyhedra which he called relu
cells in his own research
while he agreed that the boundaries
between them are not technically smooth
there are so many of them
combinatorially many possible polyhedra
in fact since each can be defined by
any combination of topologically
addressable hyperplane boundaries
there are so many yannick thinks that
neural networks can make them
effectively smooth
by arranging them so that they change
very little from neighbor to neighbor
this insight came from his work in
adversarial examples where the name of
the game is to perturb the input as
little as possible to the nearest
polyhedron with a different class
anyhow for me randall's work has
transformed the way i think about neural
networks
i know what they're doing at a much
deeper level now
each layer of a neural network
contributes a new set of hyperplanes and
the release act to toggle the
hyperplanes in an input sensitive way
every layer indeed every neuron in the
network not just the final layer
participates in placing flat decision
boundaries defining a honeycomb of
affine cells
each input signal will fall into one of
these cells and be transformed by the
combined affine transformation of every
neuron it activated
i also used to think of a single unified
latent space at each layer
however it seems obvious that any
particular input will toggle in an input
specific way a set of hyperplanes by
virtue of the release it does or does
not activate
therefore different populations of input
samples will reside in different latent
spaces at any one layer
defined by the activated set of
hyperplanes
so it seems to me that instead of having
a unified latent space
we have input specific latent spaces
plural at each layer
there's also the matter of whether
classifiers are even learning the data
manifold at all
i have my doubts
they may be learning predictably useful
aspects of the manifold
however neural network classifiers are
optimized to find class boundaries
in any structure between boundaries can
be ignored
the idea that learning boundary
manifolds necessarily means learning
intrinsic connection manifolds is where
i'm really struggling now
i can't convince myself that optimizing
for separation will give the same
outcome as optimizing for connection
for example training the same neural
network in two different ways
one for classification and once for
decoding or generation
will result in very different network
weights and latent structure
it's even more difficult to accept now
that i'm thinking of these manifolds as
piecewise linear
or what the neural network has learned
is combinations of separating
hyperplanes
that chop the space into single class
polyhedra
after all there is nothing in the
objective function
which cares about the structure within a
polyhedra
as long as the class is correct we're
good
nor is there anything necessarily
optimizing for global manifold structure
beyond just efficient and parsimonious
use of the available parameter space
and whatever prior structure was hard
coded by humans in the network
constraints and topology itself
randall commented in the interview that
in high dimensional spaces you can
easily separate everything but your
generalization performance might be bad
so you want to trade off separability
with dimensionality
he thinks the merit of deep neural
networks is being able to find a
non-linear transformation which retains
separating hyperplanes
while reducing dimensionality enough to
confer generalization power
i mean i couldn't help but notice that
everything in the machine learning world
is linear all the popular algorithms are
linear and any non-linearity is a trick
i mean we just apply some non-linear
transformation to the data before
running it through our algorithms just
like how it is in support vector
machines or kernel ridge regression and
gaussian processors deep learning models
are no different we're just placing
these relus all over the input space to
slice it and dice it
you know
let's think about this i mean what is
the simplest mathematical model
linear right
what's the next most simple one
piecewise linear
so machine learning hasn't even evolved
yet to the second order neural networks
in their contemporary usage only include
the minimum possible non-linearity of
piecewise linear
if they didn't an entire neural network
model could be described as one
monolithic linear function with a single
transformation matrix this view i think
should give you a cleaner and analytical
view of neural networks
now there are some reasons in my opinion
for the tendency towards linear i mean
computability is one of the reasons but
almost every part of mathematics favors
linearization whether it's newton's
method or calculus or linear algebra
solving pdes you know plenty of other
examples so it shouldn't come as a huge
surprise
not only that the function space of
non-linear functions is exponentially
larger and remember in machine learning
the big challenge is to reduce the size
of the approximation class
so what about boundaries now the purpose
of every relu cell is to define a
boundary in the ambient space to chop
off what is no longer required all you
have is a linear separating hyper plane
and downstream you work out the distance
from the hyper planes that you're on the
right side of you know the ones that
didn't get chopped off so the magic of
neural networks is actually learning
what to ignore in the ambient space
now um i think a problem with my
previous intuition is that like most
people i imagined neural network blatant
space is a bit like a umap or a disney
projection plot and this leads us to
misunderstand their behavior the latent
space that these examples get projected
into is not homogeneous depending on
which cell you fell into in the input
space or the ambient space a different
and fine transformation will be applied
sending you to a different region of the
latent space so the latent space is kind
of stitched together
like bits of a cosmic jigsaw puzzle in
the ambient space and then when you run
umap on the latent you see all of the
clusters but you'd be forgiven for
thinking that it was performing some
kind of smooth diffumorphic
transformation of the entire input space
and successive layers in the neural
network or even learning the topology of
the data manifold i think it's much
better to think of neural networks as
quantizing the input space much like a
vector search engine does using locality
sensitive hashing now imagine a
classification problem on the cartesian
plane where the upper right and lower
left quadrants are blue and the upper
left and lower right quadrants are
orange now as a minimal example if we
trained a single layer for neuron relu
neural network to fit this it will fit
four diagonal hyper planes two of which
are reflected versions of the same
hyperplane now by the way you can play
with this on the tensorflow playground
which we think is probably one of the
best tools for building strong intuition
on how neural networks work
now what it does is it shows you how the
ambient space is being effectively
subdivided by all of these addressable
hyper planes but this quadrant example
is unintuitive in the tool because
getting your head around how the release
act together to combine these hyper
planes to carve up the ambient space
isn't immediately obvious
now when you run the tool on a more
complex example so for example a spiral
manifold you'll now see the artifacts of
these hyper planes everywhere when these
piecewise linear chops are composed
together in the second layer we get a
decision surface in the ambient space
which can appear smooth given enough
pieces but it's actually a composition
of piecewise linear functions now as you
can see it's just chopping up the input
space in every neuron in the first layer
each one with a different angle and
translation and when you get to the
second layer it's chopping up the space
in a more sophisticated way by composing
together the chops from the previous
layer now the first thing to realize
here is that for each test input example
and every example in its vicinity its
class projection is definable with a
single affine projection there's no
continuous morphing going on here it's
more like a jigsaw puzzle being pieced
together to form many parts of a bigger
ambient space
now oftentimes we see negative weights
which actually allows the hyperplanes to
combine in interesting ways to kind of
partially cancel each other out to allow
more complex decision boundaries
any hyperplane can be reused by multiple
other neurons whichever neurons it can
reach via some topologically addressable
pathway every hyperplane can be the face
of multiple polyhedra in the ambient
space this is how they share information
and it should be obvious by now that
there are two to the n addressable
polyhedra in the ambient space where n
is the number of neurons now we also
observe that the neural network is only
capable of slicing and dice in the input
space with flat planes the only smooth
non-linearities enter the picture here
where we as data scientists linearize
the data by performing some smooth
non-linear transformation before it even
enters the neural network much like is
the case with other machine learning
algorithms now um even on the spiral
data set example the quickest way to
make the neural network fit the data is
to effectively linearize the data by
applying a non-linear transformation
before it even gets in
now we also played around with this kind
of contrived circular manifold data set
where there's a ball of data encompassed
by a circle around it and it's possible
to do a better job on that with one relu
neuron right but with two non-linear
transformations of the input data set
rather than fit this huge bunch of
piecewise linear rallies on the ambient
data i mean it should be obvious right
but this idea that you don't need
feature engineering and neural networks
i think is nonsense
now given how obvious it is that neural
networks are just chopping up the input
space with these piecewise linear
functions it begs the question how could
they possibly extrapolate in any
meaningful way right especially in the
general setting and um
but by the way when we say extrapolation
we're talking about this more general
sense of continuing the pattern not the
convex whole notion in the uh given in
the paper
regarding these piecewise linear
functions i remember an impactful moment
from more than 20 years ago in grad
school
a visiting professor who had multiple
science and nature publications you know
a pinnacle of academic achievement
was sharing his insights on how we
students might also extract such papers
ourselves from nature
and he was showing figures from his
paper and they all had two things in
common
first they depicted very simple
relationships that were previously
undiscovered okay
and second all the fitted models were
piecewise linear
he even explicitly commented along the
lines that of course there's some
underlying
smooth non-linear relationship
but absent a solid theoretical model of
that which is often going to be the case
for new discoveries
you're better off with simple piecewise
linear models
i guess when in doubt occam's razor
always makes straight cuts
and now it's clear to me that the
successful deep networks of today are
following that advice
if you've ever wondered why piecewise
linear activation functions are
dominating the field maybe it's because
they've abandoned all pretense at
finding smooth non-linear models
and are keeping it simple by fitting
piecewise linear models
albeit at machine scale with billions of
parameters
randall's spline work makes that bit of
philosophical insight brutally clear in
my opinion
it conjures the scene of darth vader
that
cybernetic warlord towering over a
growing neural network saying
embrace your hyperplanes
now you know i've always been skeptical
and often remind us of the limitations
of today's machine learning i'd say
things like
ml isn't magic learning
but for a moment i too allowed myself to
become deluded into thinking that they
are creating some kind of non-linearity
beyond piecewise linearity
but relu is by far the dominant
activation function
because it stops pretending at anything
other than piecewise linear
just stick in a flat boundary threshold
and the line
a neuron puts in a hyperplane and then
lets the rest of the network
chop more as needed
all the success of neural networks seems
explained by piecewise
linear functions
i also find it intriguing that our own
brains our own wet neural networks
have somehow gained access to smooth
non-linear imagination
just look at the laws we've defined in
physics
many exhibit non-linear but smooth
structure
on the other hand
neural networks chop up the input space
with flat boundaries and sharp edges
how can we possibly expect them to learn
or discover
the kinds of smooth relationships that
seem fundamental to science and reality
all feature engineering and
representation learning and machine
learning is about finding these
interpretative representations now i saw
a really interesting example of this
when i was reading francois chorley's
book recently and
he spoke of pixel grids of watch faces
right now they're not interpolative in
the ambient space um if you take the
average of two of these images you'll
just get four faded
clock hands on top of each other right
super posed not very helpful but however
if you represent the hands with
euclidean coordinates then the problem
becomes more interpolated but you're
still still not all the way there
the the average of two points of
interest doesn't fall on this intended
circle manifold that we're interested in
um you know it would be interpolated if
we use some relevant um distance
function which was some geodesic
interpolation
but you know anyway if we encoded the
problem using polar coordinates then it
becomes linearly interpolated right the
problem is solved and you can generalize
perfectly to any new clock face but uh i
mean in that case you wouldn't even need
a neural network and the kicker is that
we as data scientists would have to
figure this out
um ourselves right the neural network
wouldn't be particularly efficient at
doing so
especially if we the data scientists
didn't feed in the relevant non-linear
transformation before it went into the
uh to the to the model so anyway if
there exists a non-linear transformation
of this problem then you know which
makes it interpolated then we can say in
some sense that it's got a lower
intrinsic dimension
so crucially deep learning models they
can be understood as unconstrained
surfaces they do have some structure
coming from their architectural priors
but that structure only serves to
restrict the search space to a smaller
space of unconstrained surfaces it
doesn't provide the kind of inductive
prior that would enable stronger
generalization a model architecture does
not contain a model of the domain except
in the extremely restricted sense of
injecting priors such as as no
translational equivariance in
convolutional neural networks if you
want to generalize in a more systematic
fashion you either need a model with a
strong inductive prior or a model which
doesn't operate by empirically slicing
up the ambient space yeah like a like a
deep learning model does
a discrete symbolic program would be an
interesting alternative i mean just
imagine the program y equals x squared
it generalizes to any arbitrary number
right because it's highly structured you
can fit it with three training points
and once fit it'll generalize to
anything even things that are outside of
the training range but the kicker of
course is that you wouldn't know which
curve to use if you only saw three
points in the first place
now let's think of another example and
imagine um a discrete staircase space so
in this particular example an
unconstrained curve gives you complete
garbage but a structured model with the
correct priors you know it can still be
a curve will generalize in the
extrapolation regime and this prior
basically means that you need to encode
it or linearize it before it even gets
into the neural network
in both cases you're making the neural
network work extremely well for a
specific thing but not very well for
generalizing between new tasks
so anyway when we say that deep learning
models generalize via interpolation what
we're really saying is that these models
that we're using today they work well
with data that's within the training
distribution of the problem right um
well a problem that's intrinsically
interpolated but they won't generalize
systematically to anything else you
won't generalize when looking at
problems that are not interpolated in
nature and problems that are outside the
training distribution
so why do we talk about this binary
notion of extrapolation well the problem
with the binary convex whole notion of
extrapolation is that we're promoting
this idea that the moment an example
falls epsilon outside the hole that the
prediction qualitatively changes instead
i think it would be more of a distance
question right which is to say the
further away you get from this convex
hull the greater the uncertainty it's
not like you fall off a cliff when you
step outside the convex hole your
approximation of the latent manifold
remains valid for a little while
although it will quickly degrade as you
move further outside unless your model
has some strong structural prior that
matches the regularity of that later
manifold so this brings up an important
point right the relevant question is not
whether you're inside or outside the
convex hole it's how far you are from
the nearest training data points if
you're outside the convex hull but you
remain close to the training data then
your model remains an accurate
approximation of the latent manifold and
even if you're inside the convex hole
you're in a region that wasn't densely
sampled at training time right where
there's no nearby training points your
unconstrained model may not accurately
approximate the latent manifold so
inside or outside doesn't really tell
you very much it's all about the
proximity you're performing local
generalization and the quality of your
ability to generalize to new situations
depends entirely on their proximity to
known situations however if you're
dealing with training data that is
densely sampled within a certain region
of the problem space then the question
can i generalize here becomes
approximately equivalent to is this
inside the convex hole or outside now
the whole point of feature engineering
is to make data sets interpolative you
know either us data scientists design
the features by hand or neural networks
learn them as part of the training
process in big air quotes for the
podcast listeners
so um you know i think when folks make
the argument that machine learning
models generalize via interpolation or
the computer vision data sets you know
that they're interpretive what they mean
is that there's an encoding space for
which the problem becomes interpolative
or there exists a non-euclidean pairwise
distance function between the instances
that makes the problem interpretive
which is basically the same thing
so um you know if it's possible to do
this then you can say that the problem
is intrinsically interpretive but your
current representation of the problem is
not so the key endeavor in machine
learning is to find better
representations representations which
reveal the interpretative nature of the
problem
now
you might just cynically write off this
paper as being a trivial finding right
you know it it seems trivial that the
pixel space is not linearly
interpolatable something that we've
known about for decades i mean that's
why computer vision engineers in the
1980s would write feature detectors to
create an interpretative space for
machine learning algorithms to work on
right if you take any two images and you
interpolate between them what do you get
you just get a faded copy of both
everyone in the field has known about
this for decades right that
um
that examples are not interpretive in
their original encoding space or their
pixel space um i think the most
important thing though is that this
paper also shows that the models are not
interpretive in their latent space
either
that's a shocker
now what does randall say about all of
this well randall bellistrio thinks that
the steel man for this interpolation
argument would be well what if you had
very low dimensional kind of like
approximation of your data
with very few factors of variation which
could be easily linearized in the latent
space
then
it might be interpolative
randle thinks that the very concept of
interpolation i mean it was defined
about 50 years ago to describe these
very small models with very few factors
of variation and they're just not
relevant today right um they showed in
their paper that even in the relatively
small latent space on popular on a
popular neural network classifier
interpolation does not occur he thinks
that most people think of interpolation
by kind of conceptualizing their data
into a few important latent factors you
might have dogs for example and they
might exhibit a latent color and a new
color might be an interpolation between
observed colors but these guys think
that we need to have an entirely new
definition of interpolation i think the
main purpose behind their paper
according to them is to show that even
though the intuition that people have of
interpolation works well in low
dimensions it falls down completely flat
on its face in higher dimensions
actually the probability of your test
data being in the convex hull of your
training data is near zero past a
certain number of dimensions so the
current definition of interpolation
which is to say like this notion of
convex whole membership it's too rigid
to think about how interpolation works
in neural networks
so randall thinks that any new
definition of extrapolation
should be directly linked to
generalization itself this is what
they're trying to get at this is a clip
from our show with professor max welling
the first thing i want to say there is
no machine learning without assumptions
it's just basically you have to
interpolate between the dots and to
interpolate means that you have to make
assumptions on smoothness or something
like that so the machine learning
doesn't exist without assumptions i
think that's very clear but
you know clearly it's a dial right so
you can have on the one hand you can
have problems with a huge amount of data
it has to be available clearly
and there you can dial down your
inductive biases you can basically say
that that the data do the most of the
work in some sense
now i think it's a good thing to build
intuition about machine learning
principally as an interpolation problem
right so we're given the training data
and we need to cleverly interpolate
between the training examples to reason
about the statistical context of the
test examples this is what machine
learning is in a nutshell and actually a
researcher friend of mine
from meta ai research in silicon valley
a guy called dr thomas lux he published
a paper a couple of years ago called
interpolation of sparse high dimensional
data and he showed that it was indeed
possible to perform competitively with
multi-layer perceptrons for a regression
problem using pure play interpolation
methods like voronoi and the law knight
triangulation and spline methods i mean
think of creating um simplexes of the
nearest neighbors around your training
data and then averaging the results
together this simple method works
remarkably well up to about 30
dimensions i mean obviously eventually
it gets deranged by the curse of
dimensionality but
as we'll discover slightly later neural
networks might have a slight advantage
over pure play simplex interpolation
just because they work principally by
figuring out boundaries of the input
space to exclude
so you know if you're on the zero side
of the relu that is so that helps a lot
in high dimensions when you have a poor
sampling density in a particular region
of the input space but anyway if you do
principally think of machine learning as
being an interpolation method it raises
some interesting ideas you know thomas
said to me that the crux of the problem
is that we're trying to approximate a
function that has spatially unique
behavior in more than about 20 or so
dimensions like in that case it's
hopeless there's no question about it he
says that you can increase the data
density you know like in 100 dimensions
but to get a grid with 10 points on a
side you know which is to say 10 to the
power of 100 there aren't enough protons
in the universe that could convexly
cover it so and thomas concluded by
saying what this means is that
everything that we do successfully
approximate now with millions or
billions or even trillions of data
points which accounts for a lot of the
successes in machine learning
these data sets only have spatially
novel behavior in very few dimensions
right or a varying gradient in very few
dimensions 16 or fewer if we suppose
that the true function has a varying
gradient in more than that many
dimensions there's simply not enough
data in the world to approximate it the
mathematics here is unequivocal
so what actually happens
when the test examples are outside the
convex hull of the training data what
happens when we're in an extrapolative
regime well it's increasingly impossible
in high dimensions for the training set
to be statistically representative of
the test set test set instances will
often distinctly differ from anything
that we've seen during training in
machine learning the test set will never
fully characterize the problem they were
interested in so in high dimensional
settings features are often linearly
correlated as well which makes it
challenging to know what information to
use and what to discard this is another
fundamental problem of machine learning
many machine learning approaches depend
on modeling these local statistical
relationships between the training
samples but in high dimensions the
probability of a new test example being
in the convex hull of the training data
goes to zero extremely quickly so making
machine learning models work in an
extrapolative regime necessitates the
introduction of inductive biases which
are a way of adding a kind of enforced
smoothness to the model predictions so
if you hit the right bias
then it can be beneficial
if you
you know impose the wrong bias then it's
going to hurt you and this is a
well-known trade-off so of course the
whole
endeavor of machine learning is defining
the right inductive biases
and leaving whatever you don't know to
the data and then basically learning to
focus your models on the data that
you're actually seeing
this is how we stop models from fitting
the noise in the data
or going completely haywire outside the
convex hull of the training data
extrapolation requires that sensible
answers are given for all of the
elements of the input space even in
regions not seen during training and in
particular those within the convex hull
of let's say some hypothetical
infinitely sample training data set
now what we do in neural networks and in
many other machine learning algorithms
for that matter is we just take a bunch
of parameterized basis functions and we
stack them and we fit them to our
training data until it's well described
the most important considerations for
interpolation are the smoothness and
robustness of these models right we want
our models to produce gradual changes
between the training points points
outside the training set should be
handled with great care but what exactly
that means depends greatly on the
problem
in order to even know that we're in an
extrapolative regime the basis functions
must be based near to the training
examples
typically neural networks do not behave
sensibly in regions where there's no
training examples right because their
learned basis functions have been
localized around the training data in
the ambient space
it's also worth noting that
extrapolation and interpolation are two
completely different regimes optimizing
for one typically means being worse at
the other
now randall said that the boundary view
of neural networks is very clear in the
discriminative setting you only need
interpolation to try and understand how
neural networks work in the generative
setting this is a key point in the
generative setting when you interpolate
the latent we see at first glance what
looks like geometric morphing right
looking at this you'd be forgiven for
thinking that we're traversing some
smooth latent manifold but on closer
inspection it's not geometric or
diffiomorphic at all it's more of a
fuzzy high resolution fade-in
now one commonly used visual argument
for the manifold hypothesis is the mnist
digit interpolation in a generative
model our own investigation shows that
there's a degree of cherry-picking and
some of the visual examples used to
demonstrate this it's not actually hard
to stumble across cases where purported
manifold interpolation is no better than
ambient space linear interpolation there
are many examples where latent space
interpolation gives superposed and fuzzy
intermediate representations and even
crisp images which are unrecognizable
the blur and cutting and gluing which is
apparent on these images show that it's
definitely not a diffiomorphism in the
ambient space and even though the
interpolation path is continuous in the
latent space it's questionable whether
that path is semantically relevant to
the classification task at hand
i mean just think of the mean value
theorem it tells you that if you take
the value of any continuous function at
two points right um you can also find a
point between them where the function
hits the average of those values so in
other words any continuous function
produces a manifold but that doesn't
tell you anything interesting about the
function beyond what we already know
right that it's continuous
now i'm not so sure that these manifolds
are even smooth when we're talking about
smoothness we're only talking about
local smoothness and inside the
polyhedra's convex hole it's linear
right but there's no smooth surfaces or
manifolds anywhere to be seen
for any particular node in a neural
network it's actually a linear function
of a subset of the upstream linear
functions right very much like a
decision tree but with information
sharing
now another often used visual aid is
this idea that a neural network is
effectively uncrumpling and smoothing
the ambient space much like you would do
with a sheet of paper with successive
transformations in the layers of the
neural network keith and i previously
agreed with this view of neural networks
as progressively kind of flattening out
the paper but it now seems to us like
they may instead be progressively
inserting planes
aligned to the facets of the paper ball
to chop out locally affine polyhedra or
cells to cover the paper's polyhedra so
for us this is an entirely new way to
think about neural networks okay so in a
way this is a new parlor trick right do
you remember that thing the game of life
conway's game of life it looks like the
shapes are smoothly morphing but they're
actually toggling pixels with discrete
rules gary marcus talks about the pilot
trick of intelligence but isn't it
ironic that there are more parlor tricks
going on than most people realize namely
that rather than doing smooth geometric
morphing via interpolation these
networks are actually chopping up and
composing linear polyhedra
now if you interpolate between two
latent classes it might traverse several
polyhedra in the intermediate space
along the way it would pick up
characteristics from all of those
polyhedra some of the black regions are
impossible regions so it's not possible
to get there from the latent space which
is very very interesting and you only
see the illusion of continuous morphing
where the neighboring cells are very
small and very similar this is professor
michael bronstein i like to think of
geometric deep learning as not a single
method or architecture but as a mindset
it's a way of looking at machine
learning problems from the first
principles of symmetry and environments
and symmetry is a key idea that
underpins our physical world and the
data that is created by physical
processes and accounting for this
structure
allows us to beat the curse of
dimensionality in machine learning
problems
so what is the manifold hypothesis well
natural data falls on smooth manifolds
the manifold hypothesis states that real
world high dimensional data lie on low
dimensional manifolds embedded in the
high dimensional space when people
invoke this hypothesis in a machine
learning context they're generally
suggesting that neural networks are
actually learning this data manifold
which we now find quite hard to believe
frankly at best we think they're
learning some approximate aspects of it
so essentially all machine learning
problems that we need to deal with
nowadays are extremely highly
dimensional
even basic image problems live in
thousands or even millions of dimensions
now i think most people have this
intuition of convex whole membership
which is to say in two dimensions as you
sample more and more training data the
convex hull eventually fills the entire
space but the kicker is that in higher
dimensions the space is so vast this
will never happen
high dimensional learning is impossible
due to the curse of dimensionality it
only works if we make some very strong
assumptions about the regularities in
the space of functions that we need to
search through the classical assumptions
that we make in machine learning are no
longer appropriate so in general
learning in high dimensions is
intractable the number of samples grows
exponentially with the number of
dimensions and the cursive
dimensionality refers to the various
phenomena that arise when analyzing and
organizing data in high dimensional
spaces that do not occur in low
dimensional settings such as the
three-dimensional physical reality of
everyday experience
now the common theme of these problems
is that when the dimensionality
increases the volume of the space
increases so fast that the available
data becomes sparse and this sparsity is
problematic for any method that requires
statistical significance in order to
obtain a statistically sound and
reliable result the amount of data
needed to support the result grows
exponentially with the dimensionality so
you know the cursive dimensionality in a
nutshell is that the probability of a
new data point being inside the convex
hull of your training data decreases
exponentially with the number of
dimensions
as an example to estimate a standard
normal density in 10 dimensions with a
relative mean square error of 0.1 using
an efficient non-parametric technique
would require more than 800 000 samples
now um in the last show we discussed
geometric deep learning in great detail
and some you know in some sense
extrapolation and the curse of
dimensionality are analogous the reason
that these folks wanted to combat the
curse of dimensionality was they wanted
to build models which could extrapolate
outside the training range using
geometrical priors i think it's possible
to build understanding of the curse of
dimensionality through visual analogy to
familiar lower dimensional shapes such
as circles squares balls and cubes
imagine perfectly sampling an entire
space with a regular grid
this would partition space into squares
or cubes or hypercubes
with a sample in the center of each
now imagine around each sample
a disk or ball or hyperball
representing that point's region of
nearness or influence
and let's ask how much of the total
volume of that points grid cell is
actually near the sample
the answer is a fraction which
diminishes faster than exponentially
with increasing dimension
first think of the 2d case a disc or 2
ball with diameter 1 inscribed in a
square or 2 cube with sides of length 1.
in each corner we of course have a
dart-shaped chunk that isn't covered by
the disc
a trick to think about this which i
think will help in higher dimensions
is to imagine scanning a line segment
along one dimension from side to side
at the edge of the square
none of the segment is covered by the
disk
at the very center the entire segment is
covered by the disk
and then as it scans towards the other
edge of the square the covered section
begins shrinking and then rapidly falls
to zero
the total coverage then is just the sum
over that scan
in two dimensions that is just the area
of the disc with diameter one
and is about 79 percent
extending to three dimensions imagine a
ball in a cube
and we scan a square from one face
through the ball to the opposite face
as it passes the center we have our
familiar inscribed disc in a square
this is already missing the corner darts
and as we scan towards the edge of the
cube the darts expand and surround the
disc as it shrinks to zero
so by adding a third dimension we've
lost even more coverage
and the volume of a diameter one ball is
only 52 percent
in fact if we continue on the higher
dimension
the volume of a diameter one hyperball
decays faster than exponential
factorially fast in fact
the volume decays so fast
that even if we allowed for sampling
with the best possible densely packed
balls
theoretical work on hypersphere packing
tells us that the volume occupied by
optimally packed hyperballs
would still decay at least exponentially
with increasing dimensions
this is the curse
as dimensionality grows
space expands exponentially
points grow further apart
and the volume near each point
vanishes
in this episode our guests argue this
curse dooms traditional concepts of
interpolation
even if we allow for the high
dimensional transformative power
of deep neural networks
yeah so the course of dimensionality it
refers generally
to them
to the inability
of
algorithms
to keep certifying certain performance
as the data becomes more complex and
data becoming more complex here means
that you have more and more
dimensions right more and more pixels
and so this inability
uh
of you know like scaling basically it's
like it really says that if i scale up
the input
my algorithm is going to have more and
more trouble to keep the base and so
this this curse
can take different flavors right so this
curse might might might have like a
statistical reason in the sense that as
i make my input space bigger
there would be many many many much
exponentially more uh
functions real functions out there that
would explain the training set that
would basically pass through the
tingling points
and so the more dimensions i add the
more uncertainty i have about the star
that the true function right so i would
need more and more training samples to
keep the pace
these the curves can also be from the
approximation side right so in the sense
that my the number of neurons that i
mean that i'm considering to approximate
my target function i may need to keep
adding more and more neurons at the rate
that is exponential in dimension
and there and the curves can also be
from the computational side right the
sense that the if i keep adding
parameters and parameters protest to my
training model i might have to optimize
uh you know to to to solve an
optimization problem that becomes
exponentially hard
and so you can see that you are
basically bombarded by three different
by all angles and so
an algorithm like you know here in the
context of statistical learning or like
learning theory if you want having a
kind of a
theorem that would say yes i can promise
you that you can learn you need to
actually solve these three problems at
once right you need to be able to say
that that in their conditions that
you're studying you have an algorithm
that it does not suffer from
approximation or statistical or
computational curses
so as you can imagine it's it's very
hard right
today is a big day here at machine
learning street talk we have invited one
of the godfathers of deep learning on
the show
none other than professor yan la
machine learning royalty he is meta
chiefs ai scientist and a turing award
winner which i don't have to tell you is
a big deal
widely recognized as the nobel prize of
computing
ian lapoon was born in the suburbs of
gay paris in the 1960s
he received his phd in computer science
from the modern day saborn university in
during which he proposed an early form
of back propagation
which is of course the backbone for
training all neural networks
whilst he was at bell labs he invented
convolutional neural networks which
again are the backbone of most major
deep learning architectures in
production today
he has been at new york university since
2003 where he is still the professor of
computer science and neural science
apart from being perhaps the most known
researcher and main ambassador for deep
learning he has championed
self-supervised learning and
energy-based models in 2013 he created
the hugely prestigious iclr conference
with joshua bengio
a lover of the green screen i see
well normally uh
normally i when i use zoom i i put a
substituted background well tim could do
it for you and post if you want
um if you want well it's never a very
good cutout i did hack together some
python code to do it but um there's no
substitute for the real um
yeah i attempted to do this i'm i'm
running linux so i'm i attempted to do
this by you know making like a fake
video driver but it introduces a little
bit of delay so
professor lacoon it's an absolute honor
to have you on the show when i first
started mlst with with the anakin and
keith and connor we were discussing how
long it might take to finally get the
main man himself on the show
you've been a huge inspiration to all of
us here on mlst and also you've inspired
millions around the world to embark on
you know successful careers in data
science and to dream about what might be
possible with artificial intelligence
now um we've read your recent paper
learning in high dimensions always
amounts to extrapolation which he
co-authored with randall bellistrio and
jerome pogente let's get straight into
it
so um we were wondering why did you
write this paper basically um
you know
we were we were thinking um whether
interpolation and extrapolation is a
useful dichotomy i mean at the end of
the day we measure performance of
learning methods with accepted metrics
of predictive performance such as
accuracy so suppose everyone adopts your
linear convention which is a convex
whole membership and concludes that high
dimensional learning is always
extrapolation how is that useful what do
we do with this knowledge and vice versa
suppose that everyone adopts a different
definition and concludes that learning
is always interpolation what difference
would that make in machine learning
research and practice so you know in
some why is it important to distinguish
whether we're predicting by
interpolation or extraction okay very uh
very interesting question um so first of
all you this may be the first time uh
you have me as a
interviewee but i've watched bunch of
your videos so you've had me as an
audience at least
which i find really interesting actually
so um
the answer to your question is the whole
point of the paper is to show that this
notion of
interpolation versus extrapolation is
not useful
um essentially
uh that you know there's been a lot of
people
uh
who who've been sort of
saying there's a limitation to deep
learning let's say or machine learning
more generally uh because it's obvious
that those things basically do curve
fitting and that only works for
interpolation and not for extrapolation
and that kind of uh
dismissal always sounded wrong to me
because uh in high dimension your
geometry in high dimension is very
different from what we uh
the intuition that we form with you know
curfitting and low dimension right
um so
part of the motivation for this paper it
was to kind of uh you know perhaps give
help some people give you know get gain
some intuition about what really uh is
taking place uh in in machine learning
and how dimension
and also kind of uh
you know dispel the myth uh essentially
that machine learning and deep running
in particular uh only does interpolation
of course it depends a lot on your
definition of interpolation
so here we adopt a definition which is
you know an obvious and simple
generalization of uh
interpolation in in low dimension which
is you know you interpolate when a point
is in between the points you already
know
um
and the generalization to this of this
in high dimension is you know you
interpolate when a new point is inside
the convex hole of the points that
that you already know
now um
what you have to realize of course is
that in high dimension the volume of
that space is actually tiny
compared to
the overall volume of space that would
be filled you know in highly mentioned
and so that's kind of the intuition
behind this paper that
you know any new point regardless of how
you you you sample it to some extent
uh any kind of reasonable ways to to
sample points um
uh
you know in high dimension new points
are always going to be outside the
convex all almost always going to be
outside the convex hole with existing
points
uh with that definition interesting now
there's a second part of your question
is that you know is there a more
sensible definition of uh interpolation
extrapolation
and the answer is probably yes you know
the paper doesn't address it but there
are other definitions of
hulls if you want they're not
necessarily convex holes or they're not
necessarily the usual type of convex
holes so for example there is a
definition
of a hull
for a cloud of points that would be the
smallest
um
hyperboloid
paraboloid or or ellipsoid i should say
actually
the smallest ellipsoid that contains all
the points right so some points are
going to be on the on the surface of the
ellipsoid but most of them are going to
be inside
and and for for this type of and now
your definition of interpolation is that
is a new point likely to be inside the
ellipsoid of your previous point or
outside
and the answer to that is probably very
different from the one in the paper
in the sense that
it's very likely for a lot of natural
data new points are likely to be inside
the the containing ellipsoid
so it very much depends on what what you
mean but it's just that the notion of
interpolation in high dimensional space
uh you know or intuition are kind of
biased toward low dimension and we have
to be very careful what we what we say
um so that that's that was the main the
main thing and um you know
we have a bunch of uh you know it turns
out mathematicians have worked on this
on these questions for many years and
there's a whole bunch of theorems about
this that we survey in the paper
very interesting well we'll dig more in
into that in in a second but
folks like gary marcus make the case
that deepleni models don't reason and
only interpolate now i know you disagree
vehemently but my intuition is that
reasoning and extrapolation are somewhat
synonymous um is it
you know by arguing that deep learning
models extrapolate are you kind of
making the argument that they reason as
well because that would make a strong
case that deep learning models could
scale to artificial general intelligence
okay so no the short answer is no
um but but there is uh
there are important questions um
in there first of all you know what's
our definition of reasoning
uh what is the the process by which we
elaborate models and is there a
qualitative difference
between uh
a models that merely performs skirt
fitting
as we normally know it
and a model that has a
let's say to to adopt a terminology that
others have proposed
that models that establish sort of a
causal model of the the data you're
observing
uh which can be the basis for for
reasoning and and and things like that
right
um
and the answer to this is probably no
there is a difference of course but is
it an essential qualitative difference
i'm not entirely sure
and then there is the
the argument
if there is a qualitative difference
which i'm not sure about um
would this qualitative difference be in
the form of
uh fundamentally different things from
deep learning you know things that are
you know like discrete symbolic
reasoning or or things of that type and
to that my answer is clearly no i do not
believe that's the case
um so i i think reasoning is certainly i
mean i always list in my talks uh
you know the ability giving the ability
to learning machines to reason
uh is one of the main challenges of the
next uh decade or perhaps couple decades
in uh
in ai
so i i you know i'm clearly aware of the
fact that they don't do this very well
at the moment the big question i think
is how do we get machines to
reason in ways that are compatible with
deep learning
because most of the criticism that i've
heard from gary marcus and and several
others towards deep learning is not a
criticism towards deep learning it's a
criticism towards supervised learning
and i agree with them
supervisioning
sucks i mean it's very limited in the
sense that you can train machines to do
very specific tasks and because they're
trying to reverse very specific tasks
they're going to use all the biases that
are in the data to
to do that task and if you try to get
outside of that tags they're not going
to perform very well that's a limitation
of supervised learning it has absolutely
nothing to do with deep learning
so
regardless of which learning techniques
you're going to use you're going to have
that problem it's a problem with
supervised learning so i take exception
with the confusion
between deep learning and supervised
running now of course today most of
supervisory is deep learning but uh but
it's a limitation of supervised running
and as
i have been uh as you probably know i've
been a very strong
advocate of
uh self-supervision sort of moving away
from tax specific uh supervision
learning uh towards you know more kind
of generic learning followed by uh
specialization you know using supervisor
reinforcement learning
um and uh
you know in that i've i've kind of
followed the the path of jeff intern
who's been basically
uh you know i've been advocating for
this for over 50 40 years now
and you know for me it's less time i i
disagreed with him originally and
changed my mind uh about about 20 years
ago
so um
so that's the that's that's the that's
the story really
it's it's awesome that you have the
ability to to change your mind and and
admit that this is a good thing you know
we run into so many people that are just
they don't want to change their mind no
matter what you know it seems it's seen
as a bad thing which it isn't at all
no i mean i think the the essence of
being a scientist is to be able to
change your mind in the face of uh
evidence um you're not you cannot be a
scientist if you
if you have preconceived ideas on the
other hand
i've also been known
uh to to hold very tight to ideas that i
thought were true in the face of
considerable
uh
you know differing opinion from from my
dear colleagues so
so it also helps to have uh
you know deeply held convictions
sometimes
so to to this notion of um
interpolation
i think you know we we've also and you
mentioned this right it depends on your
definition and we've also had a little
bit of the sort of the feeling that
people might be talking past one another
when they you know criticize can it
interpolate can't it interpolate and
we've come up with this example of i
give a classifier a dog and that dog is
like the most doggy dog i've ever seen
like it's it's like such a dog it's more
dog than any dog i had in the training
data set so clearly that dog is like
outside of the training distribution
outside of the convex hull in any space
like be that the original space be that
the latent space um it's like
but all that matters is that it's at the
correct side of the classifying
hyperplane so that would not be
contained
on
sort of in the convex hull it will not
be contained in the smallest ellipsoid
and and so on so
do you think
when people talk about interpolation
they
they might be talking about something
maybe maybe different because you can
also make the example if i take the
convex hall of all the draining data
points and i take a point in the middle
of it it's the neural network gonna be
pretty bad at it right that's going to
be like a messy blur of pixels
and
it's not going to be very very good at
it so should we if you could you maybe
make the strongest argument you could
for
people saying
neural networks just interpolate
but
which what notion of interpolation would
you substitute would it be like
oh they just nearest neighbor classify
or or they just like if you had to like
give the best shot at sort of doing the
oh neural networks just do something
what would it be
um i wouldn't give any answer of this
type because uh the answer would very
heavily depend on the architecture
so uh for example if uh
most of the layers in a neural net
uh
i mean you you can use weighted sums and
sigmoids or weighted sums and values
right and that that effectively performs
uh a classification
uh you know separating the input into
kind of half
you know two two halves right with the
with the hyperplanes
but you could also use a euclidean
distance unit so you can in distance
unit compute the distance of the input
vector to
a weight vector which is not a weight
vector anymore
and then passes it through some sort of
decreasing function like like an
exponential and what that gives you is a
gaussian bump in input space where the
activity will be high if the input is
close to the the vector and low if it's
not
uh when you have a an attention layer
where you have a whole bunch of those
kind of uh you know vector comparison
where the vectors are normalized and
then you you do a soft max you're
basically doing sort of a multinomial
version of this
and so and
and this is using transformers right and
then all kinds of architectures these
days so uh those things that compare
vectors with each other and only react
to the two vectors that are nearby
do a sort of
you know glorified nearest neighbor with
some interpolation by the way most uh
most
kernel based
methods do this right uh kernel methods
basically are one layer of such
uh pos comparisons i mean comparisons of
the input with the training samples and
then you pass that through some function
you know some response function
so gaussian svms for example are the
perfect example of this and then you
take those scores and you compute a
linear combination that's glorified uh
you know interpolating nearest neighbor
to some extent transformers do this as
well transformers are the the basic
module of a transformer is basically an
associated memory that um you know
compares the incoming vector to a bunch
of keys uh and then gives you an answer
that you know is some linear combination
of values right so
um that that is a good idea uh
you know it it learns fast um there used
to be a whole series of models that were
now forgotten that are not forgotten in
the 90s called rbf networks so an rbf
network was basically a two-layer neural
net well the first layer was very much
like an svm this was before his svms
that again had uh radial basis functions
responses right uh comparing an input to
two vectors and passing it to an
exponential or something like this
and then you would initialize the first
layer you could train it with backprop
but it would get stuck in local minima
so so that wasn't a good idea you had to
initialize the first layer
uh with something like k-means or mixer
or gaussian or something like that
and then you could either just trend the
second layer or fine-tune the entire
thing with with backprop
and that worked pretty well it was
actually a fairly fast learner
they were kind of faster than neural
nets
so those things
for those things the answer to your
question is is a one type they're
basically doing interpolation
with uh kernels and uh and it's very
much like a smooth version of nearest
neighbors
um but then for classical neural nets
where you have either a hyperbolic
tension nonlinearity or a value or
something of that type something with a
kink in it or two kinks um
the the answer is different there it's a
it's a whole
uh cone of response that will you know
produce a positive response uh versus a
versus not if you take a combination of
units right
so um
what
does it make sense to talk about
interpolation in that kind of geometry
i'm not sure
um i think i think people should just
not use the word interpolation for that
uh
for that situation but but the fact that
you know kind of things
in a in a neural net the response of a
neural net actually are kind of
you know have space extend beyond the
the training points perhaps uh has
something to do with the fact that they
they do extrapolate in certain ways that
may or may not be relevant for the
problem but they do extrapolate
well so you know we talked some about
the interpolation versus extrapolation
versus what was in the paper because the
paper is is somewhat a rigid definition
it's like there's this convex hull and
if you're inside it's interpolation if
you're outside it's extrapolation and
you talked about maybe we could use a
ball an ellipsoid instead but there's
kind of a key thing there which is that
it's going across all dimensions so
the uh you know you're inside the convex
hall it's a necessary condition that on
every single dimension
your sample data point falls within the
range
of the training data we could kind of go
the opposite extreme and say that you're
interpolating if any dimension
falls within within the training domains
or rather you're extrapolating only if
every single dimension falls outside the
training range and both of those are
kind of these exponential extremes and
it would seem like the truth is maybe
somewhere in between like there's a
subset of dimensions that might be
salient for any any particular data
point
um so why are we kind of using this very
exponential extreme definition
uh it was still exponential even if you
you know you can you can try to divide
the set of dimensions into the ones that
are useful and the ones that are just
kind of nuisance parameters that are
useless
um but uh that are not relevant for the
task the task at hand but first of all
that task is very difficult i mean
basically the entire machine learning
problem is exactly that trying to figure
out you know what information in the
input is relevant for the task and and
what part is you know should basically
be considered as noise or nuisance
parameters
um so solving that problem is solving
the machine learning problem first of
all second of all what we show in the
paper is that regardless uh so what we
did you know the experiment we did um
that randall did as a matter of fact is
uh you know train uh
resnet 18 or 50 or whatever on imagenet
or cfr mnist and then take the output
representation
and and and and see whether
uh this sort of exponential uh growth of
uh
number of data points to to stay within
the interpolation regime still exists
and it still exists
it's just that the dimension now instead
of being the input dimension of the of
the data which may be very large is the
dimension of the embedding but um you
know as soon as the dimension of the
embedding is larger than
20 or so
the number of training samples you would
need to get outside of the
i mean to stay within the interpolation
regime is already going to be very large
um 2 to the 20 is a large number
so uh
you know so there's another experiment
that shows that if your entire data set
is contained within a linear subspace so
the nbn space may be of dimension 100
but your but all the entire data set is
within a linear subspace of dimension
four then what matters is the dimension
four not the dimension 100 right
so automatically uh
that that convex whole
process you know
what matters to it is not the dimension
of the input space it's the
dimension of the linear subspace that
contains all the points
um
and uh right but i think what i'm what
i'm saying though is that you can invert
the definition so that you know whether
or not you're extrapolating just becomes
one minus you know whether or not you're
interpolating or vice versa and so you
can wind up with an equally extreme
definition that concludes
everything as interpolation
so i'm just i'm just wondering you know
it seems like there should be a balance
and this kind of gets to what you said
earlier it's is there a more useful
gen or more useful definition of
interpolation versus verse extrapolation
that could have some utility for machine
learning i mean it's not clear you will
you would get much out of it i you know
i i give you a a potential candidate
which is uh you know
whether the points are contained in a
ellipsoid that contains all the points
you could make it a sphere you know a
sphere would be of course bigger volume
because the data doesn't necessarily
have the same radius in all dimensions
um but i think the result would
be fairly similar for both
uh for both those definitions that
you know in that case
things would be mostly interpolation but
that would be
kind of a weird definition of
interpolation in the sense that uh
you know it it it will rely on a false
intuition about high dimensional
geometry
okay calling it's
calling this interpolation uh basically
would mean that you have the completely
wrong idea about how things behave and
how you mentioned right geometry in our
dimension
i'm trying to get some intuition about
this because we spoke to professor
bronstein and and and his friends um
including uh joanne bruner and they're
they're talking about geometry dead
learning and and their their their
approach to defeating the curse of
dimensionality is finding geometric
priors to reduce the hypothesis space
which is quite interesting but a lot of
this is about our um intuitions of
interpolation because if i take an auto
encoder and i train it on mnist and i
start interpolating between the the
train or the test examples it is it is
learning this continuous geometric
morphing and that is what people's
intuition is about interpolation i know
you would say that's extrapolation
right oh it wouldn't yeah yeah no i
think it would be a type of
interpolation but it would be some sort
of geodetic interpolation interpolation
on a on a manifold right i mean so
certainly if you have some idea about
the structure of the data manifold
uh you can interpolate within that
manifold without you know making uh big
mistakes
but but then you know you're back to the
original problem with machine learning
what is that manifold how do you run
that manifold i mean that's one of the
essential problems
of machine learning and learning the
structure of a data manifold is a much
more complex problem
than
uh learning a task of classifying
objects on that manifold
uh for example classifying points on
that manifold
so there you know there is this old
adage by uh
you know which i used to be a
big fan of and which is why i was
disagreeing with jeff intern about the
usefulness of uh unsupervised learning
because um you know if you have a task
at hand
uh
for which you have data that you know
you can use to train a supervised system
why would you go to the trouble of
um
you know training uh uh pre-training a
system in unsupervised
uh mode knowing that the unsupervised
learning problem is considerably more
complicated both from you know from
every aspect you can think of right
um certainly from the theoretical point
of view um vladimir vapnik actually has
a kind of a
similar opinion one of the few things
that he and i agree on uh
or agreed on at least
which is you know why would you want to
solve a more complex problem than you
have to
but uh of course that forgets the fact
that you don't want to solve a single
problem you you want to take advantage
of multiple problems
and whatever data you have available
uh uh
at your disposal
uh
to prepare for
you know learning a task and and uh
the the
you know we we have access to
considerably more unlabeled data than we
have access to
uh label data and therefore you know why
not use uh enable data in large quantity
to pre-train very large neural nets so
that we can fine-tune them for the tasks
that we're interested in so that's the
whole idea of start supervised running
and of course we all know that has been
i mean that kind of strategy has been
unbelievably successful
in uh natural language processing you
know with uh
you know dinosaur encoder or master toy
encoder or birth style training uh
of transformers uh followed by you know
a supervised
phase that success has not yet
translated in the domain of vision
although
i'm i'm sort of predicting that it will
happen very soon
uh but uh yeah but i mean there's a lot
of interesting
interesting uh avenues there and and
recent progress um
and and and then there is the cake
analogy right the fact that uh every any
sample in sort of a supervised contact
give you way more information than uh a
supervised sample the label from us from
supervised running fortre reinforcement
uh
for uh
absolutely
and we interviewed uh isham so we've
done a show on self-supervised learning
we're we're huge fans of self-supervised
learning and i know your vision is is to
get to these um latent predictive models
you know that's a problem that's
something else i i changed my mind on
you know the last two years uh this may
be outside the scope of this particular
interview but um yeah there's there's
basically two major architectures right
for self-supervised learning
particularly in the context of vision
and the the main uh
characteristic of both of them is how
they
it's the fact that they can handle
multi-modal prediction right so if so if
you have a system let's say you want to
do video prediction or something like
that right so you have a piece of a
video clip you want to predict the next
video clip
or you just want a machine that tells
you whether a proposed video clip
continuation clip is a good continuation
of the previous one you don't want it to
predict you just want it to tell you
although it's a good one okay
so you have two architectures the first
one is elite and variable predictive
architecture that predicts the next
video clip
and of course you have to parametrize
the prediction with a little variable
because there are multiple predictions
that are plausible okay so i used to be
a big fan of that
and about two years ago i changed my
mind maybe a year and a half um
the the other approach is something i
played with in the early 90s came up
with some of the early models for this
and it's called the joint embedding
architecture where you have
the the first and the second video clip
both going through a neural net
and then what you're doing is you're
training the system so that the
representation of the second video clip
is easily predictable from the
representation of the first one okay so
they are you're not predicting pixels
you're predicting representations
uh but you still have a system that can
tell you here is a video clip and a
second one tell me if they are
compatible if one is a good continuation
of the other
the the main the main reason why i
stayed away from those architectures
because i knew that you had to use
um in the past you had to use
contractive learning right you have to
add pairs of things that are compatible
as well as pair of things that are
incompatible and in high dimension
there's just too many ways two things
can be incompatible and so that was kind
of due to failure and and you know i
played with this you know back in you
know this used to be called siamese
networks right in the
paper in 1992 1993 on doing signature
verification using those techniques jeff
intern had a a
slightly different method based on
maximizing mutual information with uh
his former students to becker um
but then in the last two years we've had
methods that are
non-contrastive that that allows us to
train those uh
those joint-embedding architectures so
i've become a big fan of them now
and it's because of
algorithms like uh like byol from our
friends at dpine
like
barlow twins who
whose idea came up came from uh stephan
denis who was doing a postdoc with me at
uh at fair he's now uh uh
as it's a professor at university of
alto in uh in finland
and uh and then more recently v craig
which is the a um
kind of a
improvement if you want on valor twins
that is also based on the the same idea
that jeff pinton and zubacker had of
maximizing a measure of mutual
information between the outputs of the
two networks but in a slightly different
way um so i'm i'm really excited about
those things and again i changed my mind
i change my mind all the time whenever
a good idea you know seems to
um to be overcome by a better one
so in the in this uh in this whole space
of
uh maybe interpolation extrapolation but
also data manifolds and so on what's
your view on things like data
augmentation training in simulation and
uh you know domain adaptation and so on
because it could be argued that these
things kind of increase the convex hull
of the of the training data they sort of
make the distribution
broader or is that just also out of out
of question not much i think data
augmentation does not increase the the
volume of the
of the you know of the data
point cloud if you want very much uh
because those augmentations are
generally fairly local
uh in dimensions are already explored
right so
i mean it may increase it a little bit
but not not significantly i think
i mean you know obviously that
argumentation is very useful right i
mean we've
used this for at least you know for
decades um so it's not a new phenomenon
either there's another there's a lot of
ideas along those lines right so this
this idea of uh you know it's the idea
where you
uh you give two examples and
uh you have two examples in your
training set and you and you you
actually do an interpolation in input
space to generate a fake example that's
in between the two and you're trying to
produce the intermediate target between
the two original examples mix up mix mix
up mix up yeah
there is that there's distillation you
know there is
you know various techniques like this
are basically
implicitly kind of ways to fill in the
space between samples right with other
kind of fake samples uh or virtual
samples if you want um there was um a
paper by uh patricia martin and and me
and john lanker many years ago uh we
were all at bell labs on something
called tangent prop so the idea
attention prop it was was kind of
somewhat similar the idea was uh you
take a training sample
and you're going to be able to distort
that training sample in in in several
ways you could generate uh points by
data augmentation but the other thing
you can do is just figure out the the
the the plane
in which those augmentations live
okay
and that plane is going to be attention
plane to the data manifold
what you want is your uh
for a given class for example right so
what you want is your your input output
function that the neural net learns to
be invariant to those little
distortions and you can do this by just
augmenting the data or you can do this
by explicitly having a regularization
term that says the overall derivative of
the function in the direction
of the you know spanning vectors of that
plane should be zero
or should be whatever it is that you
want it to be but the zero is a good
it's a good target for this so that's
called tension prop
um and it's a you can think of it as a
regularizer that that says you know
i don't just want
my input output function to have this
value at this point i also want its
derivative to be zero when i change the
input in those directions
um that's another
in indirect way of doing determination
without doing data augmentation
essentially
um and uh you know i think there's a lot
of those ideas that are very useful
certainly
so the
i think the there seems to be like a
spectrum you know coming back to this
interpolation extrapolation you said
yourself you don't believe neural
networks can do something like discrete
abstractive reasoning and so on no no i
didn't say that
or
yeah or i said i said you know we still
we we need to do work for them to be
able to do that but i have no no doubt
that eventually
uh they will i mean there's a lot of
work in this area already and uh i'll
give you some more specific examples if
you want i mean that was that was that
was actually kind of the nature of my
question where do you where do you think
you know there is this spectrum of what
people think neural networks uh are
doing now or will be able to do later
where do you think the the actual
biggest disagreement between sort of the
community right now lies and what can we
do to like what experiments what
evidence can we gather to solve these
disagreements
right so i think um
i think we shouldn't talk about too much
about neural networks because people
have
kind of a
really relatively narrow picture of what
a neural network is right it's you know
a bunch of layers of neurons that
perform you know weighted sums and pass
a result to a nonlinear function and
there's a fixed number of layers you
know maybe they can be recurrent but um
and you produce you produce an output
that's a very restricted view of what
deep learning systems can do
so let me take let me take an example um
of of what reasoning might mean
uh reasoning might be seen at least one
particular type of reasoning might be
seen as
uh
a minimization of an energy function not
with respect to parameters in a neural
net but with respect to latent variables
and a lot of systems that are in use
today do that
so a lot of speech recognition systems
for example have a decoder on the output
which uh you know essentially given a
list of scores for
you know what a particular segment of uh
of uh
of speech could be in terms of what
sound it could be or what syllable or
whatever
the decoder basically figures out what
is the best interpretation of that
sequence
of sound that makes it a illegal
uh sentence in the dictionary
uh techniques like this were used you
know have been used for you know
25 years now in the context of speech
recognition and handwriting recognition
even before neural nets were used for
those things so
um
you know back in the old days of hidden
markov models
uh
and and
and those techniques have been you know
really developed now if you think about
what those techniques do
first of all all the operations that are
done in those systems are differentiable
you can back properly get gradient
through an operation that will figure
out the shortest path in a in a graph
using dynamic programming
the first paper on this was in 1991 by
my friend roberto and xavier
this is not recent stuff they were
trying to do speech recognition
you can back properly your gradient
through a lot of different modules what
those things do is that they infer a
latent variable
by basically doing energy minimization
finding the shortest path in a graph is
a form of uh
energy minimization
um and so you can have in a deep
learning system you can have a module
that has latent variable and what this
module will do is is figure out a value
of the latent variable that minimizes
minimizes some energy function it could
be a prediction error it could be some
something else it could be you know
there could be regularizers in it etc
but it basically performs a minimization
and that
type of uh
operation
basically can
um
can be used to like you you can you can
formulate
most types of reasoning in that form
um now it's not necessarily in a
continuous differentiable space
but almost all reasoning even in
classical ai can be formulated in in
terms of optimizing some some sort of
function like you won't do a sat problem
right you have a collection of uh
boolean formula you want to find a
combination of variables that satisfy
this formula it's an optimization
problem it's combinatorial optimization
but it's an optimization problem you
want to do planning so planning is the
best example
so you can do a planning uh where the
thing your your you're controlling as
discrete actions and discrete states and
you have to use dynamic programming you
can you can back properly a greater
gradient through a system that does that
but more classical planning is
continuous is in continuous space so
planning for like planning the
trajectory of an arm for a robot
planning the trajectory of a rocket
what you have is a differentiable model
dynamical model of what is the state of
the system you're trying to control at
time t plus one as a function of the
state at time t
and as a function of the action you take
and perhaps as a function of some random
variable you can't
you can't measure
you know from the environment to
something like that to make it
non-non-deterministic now you can unroll
that model
so
start with you know time equals zero and
then
make a hypothesis about a sequence of
action and then apply your predictive
model of the next state of the system
and then at the end you can measure some
cost function is my is my rocket you
know docking with the space station oh
it's far away and how much fuel have i
consumed or you know whatever right or
have i you know reached the goal of the
the arm uh avoiding all the obstacles
right um so what you can do now is uh
an inference process which consists in
figuring out what is the sequence of
action i should take to minimize this
cost function according to my dynamical
model
you can do this by grading descent and
basically that's called the katie bison
algorithm um you know in in optimal
control that goes back to 1962 and it
consists of basically doing back prop
two time it's as simple as that right so
you do backflow time so in effect
optimal control uh theorists invented
backprop back in the early 60s but
nobody realized you could use this for
machine learning until the mid-80s
essentially or
just the 70s just to jump in there
because there's a little caveat there
which is that you can do that at
backprop if you have a fight like a
fixed number of steps like what backprop
can't handle is the case where i want
some expandable number of steps we have
no algorithms that can currently
optimize for example neural networks
with a variable layer
of
variable number of layers like we just
can't train those right
it's not true that's what recurrent nets
are um you can you can have a varying
number of iterations in your current net
and what i'm describing here is an
unfolded recurrent net it's the same
model that you applied every time step
right so it's very much like a recurrent
net and you can very well have an
unknown
uh number of steps you you don't know
our priority how long it's going to take
for your rocket to get to the space
station right so you may have kind of a
a large potential number of steps and
and um you can have a cost function
which will count like you know how much
time it's going to take to get there and
this will be part of the optimization
for example and this is classic optimal
controller i'm not telling you anything
that i you know that i came up with this
this is you know from at least the the
60s and 70s uh no but the back prop but
that no that variable number of layers
has to be has to be done in kind of a
classic iterative you know try out the
variable number of layers
and see what the back prop comes up with
or you start with a very large
number of layers and then let it stop
try and find but but still at the same
it's what i'm saying is there's
fundamentally two different kinds of
computation that are at play here one is
like the
finite fixed thing and then you do some
differentiable optimization on it
another kind of computation is this
discrete symbolic that has like an
expandable memory and an unbounded
amount of time to sit there kind of
computing on things okay and i put a
step right there what i'm describing has
nothing to do with symbolic discrete or
anything i understand that it's i
understand that you're you seem to be
equating a variable number with discrete
symbolic this is two different things
okay let me let me pose it in in this
form which is that i can very easily
write down a symbolic program that can
output the arbitrary digit of pi like
the nth digit of pi
nobody can train a neural network that
can do that
so what's the difference between these
two types of computation
and where in the future might we go with
neural networks or by augmenting neural
networks whether it's differentiable
turing machines or whatever you know to
try our neural turing machines to try
and bridge that gap in capability okay
before we bridge that gap okay the the
the algorithm to compute the digital pi
okay there's only a tiny number of
humans only in the last uh
you know few centuries that i figured
this one out you know i'm interested in
like you know how is it that the cat can
plan to uh jump on the table and not
fall or or even open a door or do things
like that right uh once we figure this
one out maybe we can think about kind of
more complex stuff like designing
algorithms that you know involve complex
mathematical concepts but i think we're
way you know
we're not there we're not there right i
mean we we're we're faced with you know
much more fundamental issues of like you
know how do we learn predictive models
to the world by observing it and you
know things of that type which that's
fair are much more basic you know that
most animals can can do and um uh you
know just apply it's uh
some something
yeah so because you're talking about
model predictive control and is it
possible that there are different shapes
of problem so for example some problems
are interpretive and are solvable using
um you know differentiable models do you
think there exists problems that are
quite discreet in nature and and a
different type of approach would be
required of course yeah i mean there is
certainly a lot of situations where
the
the the mapping from action to results
is is very kind of discontinuous if you
want right uh there's qualitatively
different
and
so so there are many uh
situations where or it's somewhat
continuous
and and situations where where you know
it
you change your action a little bit and
it results in a completely different uh
outcome
and so the the big question i think is
how you handle
uh that kind of uncertainty in the
search and and you can think of sort of
two extremes so at one extreme in the
continuous case is the case where you're
planning the trajectory of a rocket or
um
you know that that's that's pretty
continuous and differentiable and
everything you want and you don't even
need to learn the model you basically
write it down right
but there are situations there where you
know you're flying a drone or something
where you might need to learn the model
because there's so many kind of
non-linear effects that you know it's
probably better to learn it and people
are working on this same for like
working robots and stuff like that
then there are things that are a little
intermediate where
um there are sort of hard constraints on
what you can do so you want you know to
grab an object with a robot arm but
there is obstacles in between and you
don't want to bump into them and things
like this
so people tend to put like penalty
functions to make this sort of more
continuous but uh but there's sort of
qualitative difference between using
your left arm or your right arm for
example or or going you know you know
scratching your
your left ear with your left hand or
with your right ear you know going to
the back of your head right those are
qualitatively different solutions
um and then all the way to to the other
side there is intrinsically discrete
problems
with uh you know
that may be fully observable with some
uncertainty like chess and go playing
okay and you know uh
those we can handle to some extent
because the number of actions is finite
it goes exponentially but it's finite
and so using kind of ways to
uh direct the search
uh despite the fact that the search
space is exponential um you know using
neural nets as particularly evaluation
functions to direct the search in the
right way and doing you know
multi-colored research and and blah blah
blah
will
work okay with sufficiently many trials
uh you know in the completely
deterministic fully observable uh
differentiable case
that's classical model predicted control
that's fine
then there is some stuff they really we
really don't know how to do
and it's twofold one is the model is not
given to us by uh
equations derived from first principles
right so the stuff we're trying to do
you know is in the real world and it's
got complicated dynamics that we can't
just model from first principle so we
have to learn the model
um that's the first
the first issue second issue
the model lives in the world and the
world is not completely predictable
it may be
deterministic but
you don't have full observation so you
cannot predict exactly what's going to
happen
in the world because the world is being
the world or as a consequence of your
actions
so how do you deal with certainty and
for that you need predictive models that
can represent uncertainty and we are
back to the issue i was telling you
about earlier
uh do you need latent variable models or
jump embedding architectures right
that's uh
and i've changed my mind about this as i
told you so
um uh then there is the the third uh
obstacle which is um
is the problem we're trying to solve of
of the sort of continuous differentiable
nature or of the kind of completely
discrete
uh you know quantitatively discrete
depending on what action you take nature
and i think most problems are some
combination of the two
so
uh you know you're you're trying to
build a box at a wood or something like
that right you can make the box bigger
or smaller uh you know you can hit the
nail in this way or that way and that
may be sort of continuous and
differentiable
but then there is you know do you put
glue or screws or nails do you
or use kind of more classical carpentry
or whatever
and those are kind of discreet choices
uh what type of wood are you using you
know things like that so i think uh
the you know human mind is able to deal
with all those situations have you know
know to use
differentiable continuous stuff when
when they have to and and use the sort
of discrete exploration when when we
have to as well but we have to realize
that humans are really really bad at the
discrete exploration stuff
we totally suck at it
um
if we didn't then we would be better
than computers at playing chess and go
but we're not
we're actually really really bad
um
so
that's fascinating
so so you seem to be saying in a way
that um you are a fan of high school
models and something so something like
alphago for example i mean that that's
basically uh um there's an
interpretative space which you know
guides a discrete search let's say like
that do you think that's is that a good
thing or do you think that's that's
so you like that kind of work okay there
is there's something very interesting
about uh
uh you know in the context of
reinforcement learning about this which
is uh actual critic models right and and
you could think of uh
all of the stuff that actually works in
reinforcement running um
i mean they don't work in the real world
right but they they work in games and
stuff and simulated environment um they
very often use actual critic
type architectures
and the the idea of a critic you know
goes back to early papers by uh saturn
and bartow and the the basic idea of a
critic
is to have a differentiable uh
approximation of your value function
right so you you train
a small neural net essentially
to compute to
estimate to predict the value function
from your state
and the reason you need this is now you
can propagate gradient to it
right
so that that's kind of the first step
into sort of making the world
differentiable you're just making the
value function differentiable now inside
of the world there's two parts in my
opinion and this is the source of uh the
idea behind model based reinforcement
running is that you have the
the the model you have the world right
the world is going from state to state
um
because it wants to or because you're
taking an action
uh and then there is a value function or
you know a cost function i prefer to
talk in terms of cost function that
takes the state of the world and
and gives you kind of uh
estimate of that uh of that cost right
i'll give you the cost
now
the the the world itself and the value
function that takes the state of the
world and gives you
uh pain or pleasure right
is unknown
but what you can do
is build a differentiable model of that
right so differentiable model of that is
what npc is all about you you build a
model of the world that predicts the new
state of the world as a function of
previous state it doesn't have to be a
complete state it has to be a state
that's complete enough to contain the
relevant information about the world uh
you know related to your task right and
and then you have a differentiable
function that you learn that learns to
predict
the
reward or the cost from your estimate of
the state of the world so what you have
now is you know a neural net inside your
your agent
that uh basically can simulate the world
and simulate the
the uh
the the the cost that is going to result
from the state of the world in a
differentiable way so now you can use
uh gradient descent or gradient-based
methods
for two things one for inferring a
sequence of action that will minimize a
particular cost okay there's no there's
no learning there
two uh to learn a policy that will learn
to
produce the right action given the state
without having to do the model
predictive control without having to do
this inference
by uh
by
energy minimization if you want and
that in my opinion explains the process
in that we observe in humans by which
uh when you learn your new task you go
from the you know daniel kahneman system
two to the annual element system one
right so you know you learn to drive
you're learning to drive you're using of
course your entire model of the world
that you've learned in the last 18 years
if you are 18.
um to predict that you know when you
turn the wheel of the car to the right
the car will go to the right and if
there's a cliff knife to you the car is
going to fall off the cliff and you know
you're going to die right
you don't have to try this to know that
this is going to happen you can rely on
your internal model to uh you know avoid
yourself a lot of pain right um
and uh
and so but you pay attention to the to
the the situation you pay a lot of
attention to the situation you're
completely deliberate about it
um you you imagine all kinds of
scenarios and and
and you drive slowly so you leave
yourself enough time to actually do this
kind of uh reasoning and then after
maybe 20 50 hours of uh
of practice
it becomes subconscious and automatic
you know um
that that's even true for chess players
so that's an interesting thing about
chess right i played once i'm a terrible
chess player by the way and i played
once a simultaneous game against a grand
master um so he was you know he was
playing against like 50 other people
and so i had plenty of time to think
about my move right because uh he had to
kind of play with the 49 other players
before getting to me and so i wait for
him to come and make one move and then
you know in one second or first of all
he does
like you know as if i played something
stupid which i did and
and he moves within one second he
doesn't have to think about it right
it's completely subconscious to him you
know it's just pattern recognition right
it's got this
um you know called net predicting the
next move you know completely
instinctively um he doesn't have to
think because i'm a i'm not you know i'm
not good enough for him to to really
kind of cause his system to to uh kick
in
and of course you know he beat me in 10
you know in
10 plies right i mean um
you know as i told you i'm terrible um
you know i i learned to drive a long
time ago but as it turned out very
recently i um
i went to drive a sports car on a on a
raceway
um and and you know again you're the
first few times you're very deliberate
about it you know uh they explain you a
few things and then you basically have
to integrate all of that by yourself and
over the course of a day you get better
and better like much better
just by you know
basically compiling
what at first is deliberate into
something that becomes automatic and
subconscious
indeed and also abstractly reusing
knowledge that you've gleaned elsewhere
and applying it in a new situation but
anyway professor yan lacoon and thank
you so much for joining us today it's
been an absolute honour it's been a
pleasure um you guys are doing great
work so
you know keep going
thank you for being a fan too thank you
so much for watching thank you so much
thanks
wonderful
rando introduce yourself
okay so uh i join fair or should i say
meta ai research i guess
last june for a postdoc position
i was doing my phd at rice university
under the supervision of professor
richard bernier and during my phd i
focused on basically trying to
understand deep networks from a
geometrical point of view through spline
theory
and now i'm trying to let's say expand
my horizons and
do more diversified research topics with
jan lucca
and for this paper uh basically the main
goal was to
try to understand through a lot of
empirical experiments
what do we understand by interpolation
does it
occur in practice and does it make sense
to use interpolation as we know it
as a let's say a measure of
generalization performance for current
current networks
and the main point is really to say that
the current definition of interpolation
which uses this convex earl
might be
too rigid to really
provide any meaningful
intuition and so we either need to adapt
this definition or just entirely think
about this in a different angle but yeah
the current definition is not good
enough for the current uh data regimes
that we are in right now i don't know if
it's precise enough
perfect it's wonderful cool well
sorry we need to get into the mood again
yeah
um yeah hi randall um this it's it's
really cool to have you here we've
enjoyed reading the paper it's it's
quite a short and concise paper i have
to say and and the experiments are quite
you know i find them to be really on
point especially especially uh where you
look at the latent space
experiments because a lot of people
would say of course we're not
interpolating in data space we're
interpolating in the latent space
um yet even in the latent space you know
and we've talked a little bit about the
notion of interpolation and
extrapolation
is it fair to say that the paper is just
sort of
a negative argument it's just
is it fair to say that the main point of
the paper is
arguing
look
interpolation is the wrong concept
you're looking for when you criticize
these models
yes i don't think it's negative per se
it's more let's say a call to change the
definition for the current usage of
machine learning models
because now we are not in low dimension
regimes anymore and so using those
concepts that have been defined 50 years
ago when we were looking at univariate
models does not really make sense so i
think the intuition behind what we try
to mean by interpolation is right we
should not change that we should change
the
mathematical definition of it
and uh and yeah like you say people
could argue yes but your interpolation
is a latin space and so on but we showed
that even in a classifier setting it
does not happen and you can also show
that in a generative network setting it
will not happen again all because of the
dimensionality so it's really about uh
yeah going to the high dimensional
setting then things start to break and
we have to adapt to that basically
and we've already asked jan this
question but
if you
had to give your best shot at making the
you know the argument that these people
want to make when they say oh it's just
interpolating
if you had to give your best shot at
making that argument successfully you
know what would you change how would you
change the notion of interpolation or
what argument would you make for those
people so i think what most people try
to say is they try first to
conceptualize the data that's there so
for example you have an apple right you
have different colors
and if you think of
this color as being your latent space
then you can say okay between green and
red you have a new color but it's in
between the two you're in an
interpolation regime right so all of
this point of view is from a generative
perspective and this is because you only
think of a few factors of variations
like this and then you think okay
everything should be in interpolation
regime but even with that definition if
you start having a lot of factors of
variation then the curse of
dimensionality will kick again and you
will never be in interpolation regime
even in a generative setting so for them
the best argument would be if i don't
consider the real data set but a very
low dimensional approximation very rough
which can be explained only with a very
few factors of variation and i can
somehow linearize those factors in my
latent space then i will uh have more
chance at being in the interpolation
regime so we'll have to have a sort of
lossy
compression of your data if you will and
then you can try to reach there with
more chances so i think you just steel
manned the argument for interpolation so
that i think that's precisely what folks
do argue is happening in in a deep
neural network
do you not believe that
well as soon as you have high
dimensionality settings
then it does not happen almost surely
and i mean you could argue so for
example let's say you take a
gun or any big generative network right
in the latin space you have hundreds of
dimensions and you sample those guys
from a gaussian distribution
so even if you were saying okay your
training set is sampled from a
generative model and your test set is
sampled from the same generative model
and in that latent space you have
interpolation well it's wrong from the
beginning because in that latin space
alone you will never have a gaussian
sample that lies in the interpolation
regime as soon as the dimensionality is
greater than let's say 15 or 20. so it
does not happen because of the
dimensionality unless you have very
degenerate things of course if your
generative network just
spits out the constant then in pixel
space you will have interpolation but
this is degenerate by definition so
i'd like to i'd like to pick up on that
if you don't mind
yeah so what i want to pick up on is
again all of this hinges on definition
one which is in the paper
which is membership within this
within this convex hall and
there's a there's a sense in which
that's an extremely rigid
definition of interpolation right and
and i think i heard i think i heard you
earlier say that what we need to do is
redefine what we mean by interpolation
and higher dimension because the
intuition
of interpolation is still correct but we
need to
redefine what we mean by interpolation
so if you if you took a shot at
redefining interpolation how would you
define it what do you think is
a better definition of interpolation
so i think it's a very task dependent
so let's say you want to look at a task
which is pure object classification
in that case i think going back to what
we were saying earlier on first trying
to compress some all your data so that
you can
explain it with as little factors of
variation as possible and then you can
use the current definition just on a
compression of your data then it could
make sense
because you don't really mind about the
finicky details of your objects if you
just want to differentiate between
different classes of objects
but in another setting where you might
be trying i don't know today noise
samples or things like that then you
might want to have a very more specific
definition based on what you try to
denoise in your data and so on so i
don't think there will be a general
definition that works across the bone it
will be really dependent on the type of
task you are looking down
downstream
it's it's really it's really the key
let me throw
something out there because i've been
thinking about this
and i tried to ask uh
professor lacoon about this but i didn't
quite i didn't communicate it clearly
which is that
for something to be in the convex hall
so in in dimensions you know for
something to be within
you know a convex hull
it's a necessary condition
that on every single dimension
uh the sample data point lies within the
range that was sampled
so that's a necessary but not sufficient
condition because that that's sort of
you know the convex hull is actually
even smaller than that
in that space but it's necessary that it
be within within that bounding that axis
align bounding box it has to be inside
there yes on every dimension okay
and so what if i were to invert this and
say that well instead i'm going to
define extrapolation
as
on every single dimension it has to be
outside
the uh the sample range so in other
words the point has to be outside the
axis align bounding box that would
actually come to the complete inverse
conclusion because then exponentially so
all machine learning would be
interpolation because it's very very
unlikely that you're outside every
single
every single dimension so i'm thinking
somewhere in between there like there's
almost like a fractional
concept of uh interpolation versus
extrapolation where we can say it's
almost like
on average how many of the dimensions do
you do you hit inside the sample point
so maybe i'm inside
20 of the dimensions on average could
that be like a route to any type of yes
definition so that's actually a very
good point so basically what you are
saying is instead looking at let's say
the closest on closing hypercube and
then you say okay if you're in that
hypercube or not you're in interpolation
or extrapolation regime and
that's actually something we are looking
at right now which is not the smallest
hypercube but the smallest ellipsoid
that encloses your data and it's somehow
in between
the convex earl and the hypercube that
you mentioned so for sure there is
some
ways in between those two extremes where
you will have a meaningful interpolation
and extrapolation regime that does not
collapse
all
one way or the other way so this is for
sure one in testing route
and this could potentially be let's say
task agnostic
but then again would it be precise
enough to really quantify uh
generalization performances per se
uh i don't know yet but yeah that's
something we are looking into right now
yeah and the reason the reason that we
kind of came to that
that thought process is because there is
an intuition that
um
machine learning is kind of very good at
taking all these dimensions that we
sample
and saying you know it's really only a
subset of those dimensions that matter
at least in some transform way like like
for example
suppose i was doing um
suppose i only had 16 dimensions of
ambient space
and everybody agreed yeah given the
amount of data we have we are
interpolating like almost all the time
we're in this this rigid definition of a
convex hall and then somebody comes
along and says oh oh by the way we
upgraded all our sensors now and we
added 240 you know dimensions and if all
those dimensions happen to not be useful
for the problem that we're trying to
solve or classification problem or
whatever
it would be weird to say now we're all
of a sudden extrapolating because if the
if the if the neural network is doing
what it should be doing it will ignore
all those irrelevant definitions and
continue just calculating exactly what
it was calculating you know before
um
is that right yeah that's a very good
point but i think for this to actually
work you will need to assume that you
have enough actual samples so that when
you train your network understand that
basically those dimensions are pure
noise it does not need it to solve the
task at end and it disregards it so you
have some a regularization term that
kicks in and it does not try to use them
to minimize the training loss but i
think in practice that's not really what
we see if you take like image task
classifications even especially now with
self-supervised learning methods we see
that actually most of the information
that we could think is irrelevant for
the task is actually kept because it can
of course help in reducing the training
loss so i think that's a very
interesting point for what you said to
work you really need to be sure that
either you have the perfect regularizer
or you have the perfect model and regime
of training samples and so on but in a
general setting i think it will be
tricky to to claim it
like this
that's a very interesting point so
you're saying
when you add these extra dimensions even
to learn to ignore them
you have to have lots of data yes yes or
regularization or some mechanism that
yeah exactly
yeah very interesting
that's one thing that's one reason why
uh
let's say adult parametrization by n is
sometimes useful because if you know
priory which
things are useless for your task you can
by end remove them from the data that
you feed to your deep net or whatever
model and then doing this will improve
generalization
so
that's why in some cases is still useful
to do those let's say pre-processing
steps
right
could you give me a bit of intuition
here so um we've been listening to quite
a few folks that make the argument about
the interpretative nature of deep
learning and you could argue that any
kind of processing and machine learning
not just feature transformations but
even things like regularization and
domain randomization that they're all
ways of making the problem more
interpolative and it would be
appropriate for an interpolated problem
so i'm thinking to myself i mean in in
this example you take pictures of clock
faces and it's not interpretive in the
ambient space you perform some kind of
feature transformation there exists some
non-linear transformation that
transforms it into an interpretive space
that's what these people say but i'm
wondering um you know i'm i'm interested
in the curse of dimensionality you know
why does deep learning work at all
and i've spoken to folks that talk about
um creating various priors to combat the
curse of dimensionality but why do you
think that deep learning works at all in
these high-dimensional spaces
uh well so first
i might say something a bit
let's say
speculative or
not agreed upon by everyone but i don't
think we love it we love it please do
exactly i don't think you can state so
generally that deep learning works right
you need the right architecture you need
the right clause function they need like
everything right for it to work and
that's why it works now because we spend
i don't know much amount of money and
manpower to get to where we are now but
if you just take a plain mlp you apply
it on imagenet i don't think you will
say it's it's working right so i think
right now it's working i mean what we
have is working because we basically by
end it all the cross validation such
that uh
the network that we are using is
regularized enough
to only learn the
necessary or meaningful information or
at least as best as we can to provide
good generalization performances
so yeah it's a bit too general of a
statement to say that deep learning
works out of the box for everything
in fact i love that i love that point
yes yes many if you go into
not just image classification but let's
say audio classification and some maybe
trickier data sets i don't have a lot of
samples
then everything starts to break quite
rapidly right
you have always people trying to go into
the medical field as well but since it's
very hard to generalize between patients
between recording devices and so on
things get very very messy and
everything is
a doc
and optimization basically so yeah i
don't think we're at this point yet
where you can say yeah that's it deep
learning works yeah can i jump in real
quickly here tim because because what i
want to say is
brilliant point i mean and when you
think about it let's take a professor
look you know one of his
his great invention right the
cnn convolutional neural network that
was discovered by a human being like a
machine
and no neural network learned to do
convolution
taught machines how to do
convolution and so we we oftentimes
discount this and say look how great
machine learning works we discount all
the human engineering that has gone into
actually making machine learning work
through specific architectures yes
exactly exactly yeah that's uh basically
we are
guiding where to go and then of course
once we guide enough the machine knows
what to do i mean it's this is not a
reduction of
what we can do with deep learning right
but it's just saying that
a general statement of out of the box
deep learning works even in a new task
that we've never tried before is another
statement
but i still want to linger on this point
of why you said or here's just a random
projection of the data and then here's a
resnet projection here's a trained
resnet projection what i took from that
is irrespective it's all in an
extrapolative regime and um you know
there was a guy who posted an article
who is disparagingly saying that neural
networks are just interpolators
analogous to a taylor series
approximation within a small uh part of
the domain of a function and it goes
haywire outside of the domain and you
know there are a lot of people that that
would make that case that neural
networks cannot extrapolate outside of
the training range but but they do seem
to work remarkably well given the curse
of dimensionality so why is that exactly
so uh so let's say for simplification
that you have a binary classification
problem so once you go into your latent
space or if you just do linear
classification if you stay in your
ambient space basically you
say you have class 0 or 1 based on which
side of an upper plane
you lie in
now
if you are on the good side you can go
to the infinity right you can go to a
extrapolation regime as far as you want
from the training set as long as you are
in the correct side of that hyperplane
you will have good generation
performance so it's not
exactly
correlated the only thing you need
somehow is to have the orientation of
the axis where you will extrapolate to
be somewhat
aligned in the orthogonal space of that
type airplane once you have that then
you will generalize even though you can
be in extrapolation regime in ambient or
future space so that's one thing
that is maybe proper to linear
classification if you were doing maybe
some other type of classifier on top of
it it might change
but yeah given the current settings i
don't think people should expect bad
performance because you are not in the
interpolation regime this is quite of a
shortcut
maybe that is guided by our intuition
right we think it's much easier to
classify something if it's in an
interpolation regime but if you just
look at the plane in our classifier
that's not that's not the case
well so just to steel man a bit what the
you know what say others on the
interpolation side again that's that's
only if you're buying into a very rigid
definition of interpolation which you
know the way the paper defines it is in
a linear way i mean it's defining
interpolation by this linear
convex hull and of course you know
neural networks for example are highly
non-linear
non-linear systems and what you just
said sort of which side of a separating
hyperplane you're on that itself is a
non-linear function
and so
i think the point you made early on was
very good which is we have this
intuition of what interpolation is we
haven't yet got a good definition
for interpolation and
multi or high dimensionality non-linear
cases
but obviously the
the linear definition doesn't really
apply
yeah yeah exactly yeah it's it's uh
it's really because uh
i mean it's similar but again you can
consider your data as being non-linearly
transformed
the problem is still that if you have
high dimensionality
then to be within a convexer becomes
exponentially hard using the convex earl
of the training set if you define
something else like you said before the
hypercube it will be it could be the
opposite it's uh always an interpolation
region and the key
is uh basically to find a meaningful set
such that you don't go all the way in
one direction or the other
and because i think the main point also
is that this should give intuition into
the generalization performance of a
model right
because if you can detect okay sample is
in extrapolation regime
but your model still performs very good
on it i don't know if it has really a
lot of practical use so what would be
good as well is to have the basically
generalization performance of a model
correlate with your definition of
extrapolation and that's really what we
are trying to get
and that's why i was saying that
probably you might have a task dependent
definition because that might be where
you get the best
precise definition to reach that
i was wondering to what extent if any
any of this invalidates the so-called
manifold hypothesis so i think when most
people speak of interpolation and deep
learning their intuition is something
along the lines of well the model learns
some you know some manifold in the
latent space and interpolation means i'm
just kind of like traversing um you know
the geodesic on that manifold and when
you visualize the results on an
autoencoder or something you can see
this kind of continuous geometric
morphing of let's say one image into
another image and that manifold i think
you said in your paper that the actual
data manifold is it's not possible to
approximate that well but it it's doing
something interesting
and a prediction on on that manifold in
the intermediate space it's not
massively deranged is it it's still
doing something very useful
statistically yes yes totally so uh i
think it does not at all contradict it
and in fact uh think of a very very
simple example where you say your data
is a linear manifold of dimension 100
let's say which is a relatively
meaningful number of dimensions even for
images but now suppose it's completely
linear well even in that case it would
be hard to be in interpolation regime
just because you have 100 dimensions and
picking a new sample that lies in the
convex of your training set is
exponentially hard
so you can have a manifold for your data
it can even be linear so the simplest
manifold you wish for the only problem
is the dimensionality of that manifold
now that being said
again it does not mean that you cannot
do
basically moving on the geodesic of your
manifold or you cannot do some sort of
interpolation
because that's what happens in most of
the current state of the generative
networks right
it's just that you don't need to be an
interpolation regime to have a correct
generation process basically and that's
again one thing that is very important
and you mentioned you have those
examples
that's true that the interpolation is
extremely nice but again it does not
say that the point you start with and
the point you end up with are in
interpolation regime of your training
set so i think it's two different things
to be able to interpolate or move on
your manifold and being in the
interpolation regime from your training
set so what's kind of
what's intriguing me about
and i want to clarify something earlier
which is that um
though a hyperplane
is is a linear construct
the function that says you're on one
side or the other of a hyperplane is a
non-linear function
and and so what's
and in that case it's it's a digital
function you're either on this side or
that side it's zero one what's kind of
interesting is
you you gave that ex as an explanation
for why machine learning works at all
which is that
that for data sets that we care about or
problem problem spaces that we care
about
it seems to often be the case that we
can do enough sequences of linear and
non-linear
transformations to arrange the data such
that
it falls on on one side or another of a
separating plane so in a sense that
seems like real world data is often
separable if you do enough
of enough transformations on it and
since that separability is a very
digital concept um
is there any is there anything
interesting in that any intuition yes so
so for this you still have to be careful
right because if you go in high
dimensional spaces you can basically
separate everything
very easily but your generalization
performance might be bad so basically
what you want is really to have a
let's say a good ratio of how much to
expand dimension how much you
nonlinearly transform your data to then
reach a good generalization performance
because otherwise you can just fall back
into a kernel regime let's say
and you expand so much your space that
sure you can separate everything on your
training set but then the generation is
going to be very poor so and that's one
strength of deep networks right is that
you have so much of this non-linear
transformation that you can somehow not
expand the dimension of your space too
much or even contract it and still have
a separating hyper plane in the end
where generalization
is much higher than in other class of
models so i think the key is really uh
to have those uh meaningful none in a
transformation such that you don't have
to increase your space too much you just
shape it around if you will but yeah
that's and what you said earlier is
exactly true if you think of which side
you are in basically you are binarizing
your data right
and if you have good uh classification
it means all the classes are assigned to
the same labels which is one or zero and
if you think of it still in
interpolation region then suddenly you
are in interpolation regime right you
are a one
the new sample is a one after
binarization and you become
interpolation regime
and you have a good performance but this
comes after this
compression step if you will or
discretization step
and that might be
another direction to explore as well if
you start to quantize things or to
compress things like we were saying a
bit at the beginning then you can
reach
basic interpolation much more easily as
well
i had a couple of questions so
again in in table one it was i mean your
paper's making the argument that
everything is extrapolation given given
this convex notion in high dimensional
space but um if we if we zoom in a
little bit though so you're using a
pre-trained resnet uh classifier
pre-trained on imagenet and
how do all of these things change the
structure of the latent space in a
meaningful way and um the embedding
space is also highly distributed and we
were wondering um
you know can you give us some intuition
here so is the information likely to be
quite evenly distributed over the layton
or do you think it's actually quite
bunched up and sparsely encoded in in
few of the features
uh so i think this will depend on which
training setting you use right so for
example if you start using draw part and
things like that you will try to have a
more evenly distribution of your
information to have a more stable loss
when you drop those units so i don't
think you have a general answer for that
it will depend on the type of
regularization you have
or training is done etc but
you have to keep in mind that what you
try to do with gradient descent is just
minimize your loss right but then with
cross-entropy loss let's say your
gradient starts to vanish as you become
really good and you stop learning at
where you are basically so given that
depending on your initialization you
will still try to make the best of what
you get and even if it means learning
redundant
dimensions if this can reduce your loss
further at a more rapid rate that's what
you will do so if you don't impose any
regularization or anything there is no
uh clear reason to assume that
everything is well organized and so on
and and that's what we see even in
generative networks you have to start
putting so much regularization to try to
have
disentanglement and to try to make sense
of those flattened spaces because
otherwise you just try to learn what
minimizes your loss with the
most short-term view of your loss
landscape so basically that
that could be built if you have some
specific regularizer but otherwise
it will not occur naturally
of course if and and again if you wanted
to only retain the minimal information
to solve the task at n
then you will see much more
interpolation regime in that latin space
if you think of mnist for example you
would disregard the
translation of your digi the rotation of
the digit all those things other things
will be disregarded when you reach the
latin space and then you will basically
be in interpolation most of the
interpolation regime most of the time
but since you keep as much information
as possible to try to minimize your loss
as best as you can then
you basically occupy as much as you can
unless again you have some degeneracies
because of the whole
or architecture tricks for example if
you have a bottleneck layer right you
will limit the dimensionality
of the manifold you spawn in the latent
space so you can have all those
parameters that can play a big world so
it will be in the general setting i
don't think you could assume anything
and i think there's also a relationship
too between the
the dimensionality of the latent space
and let's say
some intrinsic dimensionality of the
problem so if
if the intrinsic dimensionality of
problem only takes five dimensions to uh
to solve and yet i give a latent space
of 256 dimensions
i think what i hear you saying is that
of course gradient descent is going to
make some use of those other
you know 251 dimensions but they're
going to have like maybe a very
minuscule or diminishing a diminishing
effect on the um on the latent space
whereas on the other hand if if i then
took that same network and increased the
complexity of the problem
we could end up with for example it's
sparsifying for any particular class so
if we're doing some multi-class problem
we may find that it sort of arranges you
know these seven
seven dimensions to solve the dog versus
hot dog problem in these um 12
dimensions to dissolve the car versus
motorcycle problem it might be forced to
make more compact use of that latent
information space per per class is that
fair yeah so that's a very good point so
uh first on the first thing that you
said
one thing to keep in mind so let's say
your data is even a linear manifold of
dimension one and then you go through a
deep net
and then somehow it's already linearly
separable then you only need to learn
the identity mapping with your deepnet
to solve the task but if you start from
a random initialization it's extremely
hard to do that right that's why people
came up with resnet and all those things
so already from this point of view it
means that almost surely your linear
one-dimensional manifold will become
highly non-linear still one dimensional
but very highly nonlinear in the latent
space of your classifier and as we
showed in the figure one of the paper
even if the intrinsic dimension is one
if you are highly nonlinear in your
space then you will basically never be
in an interpolation regime so you have
those sort of artifacts that come just
from the fact that learning simple
mapping let's say with a non-linear
deep network is not always simple and
those artifacts will be introduced
right away because it's so hard in your
parameter space to reach that point
where you have identity mapping so this
is
another effect that kicks in and that
can
somehow remove those assumptions that
even if your data is in a low
dimensional regime
and almost linear
it will be preserved in the output space
of your offshore network so this is uh
something really
really important to keep in mind as well
so um
randall i i also noticed in about 2018
uh you were the first author on some
really interesting work and it was
called a spline theory of deep learning
and then i think the next year it got
into neurops so i think you've i'm just
reading a bit from the abstract so you
said you built a rigorous bridge between
deep networks and approximation theory
via spline functions and operators and
you actually think that this can explain
you know a lot about deep learning in in
in the sense of them being a composition
of these max sapphire and spline
operators has any of this work informed
your view of deep learning now uh yes a
lot actually so i think uh so so first
of all i want to be precise that of
course a lot of people
uh knew about the fact that if you use
for example really activations absolute
value and so on or max pooling then the
wall network is a continuous piecewise
linear mapping
so what we did mostly is to make this a
bit more rigorous and try to understand
okay
what's the partition of the input space
look like and what the perigeun mapping
look like and how can we use that to
gain some more intuitions into what's
happening
and the nice thing with this is that if
you think about it there is nothing
simpler that piecewise linear mappings
right basically it says that if you are
in a region of your space region from
the partition of your mapping then the
input output mapping will stay linear
and this allows to do a lot of analysis
for example to adversarial perturbation
or all these type of things and it can
also open the door to other
line of research for example one thing
we did i think it was the rips last year
or two years ago was to use that to
derive the exact expectation
maximization algorithm for the
generative networks because now you have
a
cleaner let's say or simpler analytical
form of your network and
this really opens to me the door to
derive some more interesting theoretical
result
it does not really help intuitively
because i think everyone has this
intuition from before already but yeah
it's mostly a
mathematical tool that allows to derive
with more is some interesting results
and and i think one important thing as
well is that
you have released this dichotomy right
between the let's say
old school
signal processing template matching
type of academia researchers and the new
school with deep learning everything has
to be trained and so on and what is
interesting in this paper is that we
somehow bridge the two we say that
basically a deep net is a very smart way
to build an additives adaptive spline
which will learn automatically its
partition of the input space and the
perigeum affine mapping such that it
works in eye dimension and this was not
known before by anyone in the spline
theory if you speak about adaptive
spline in eye dimension no one has no no
idea what to do except dimension two or
three maybe because a lot of
pde work uses but outside of uh
dimension 3 no one thinks about splines
so i think there's a very
strong result just to bridge those two
different fields
that's fascinating i think one of the
issues i was speaking to juan bruno
about this and he was saying there was a
big tradition in harmonic analysis of
trying to reason about the behavior
of these models and
we did have the um the universal
function approximation theorem which in
a sense is talking about stacking uh
basis functions you know to approximate
an arbitrary function but you say in
your abstract here that the spline
partition of the input signal opens up
in a new you know opens up a new
geometric avenue to study how deep
neural networks organize signals in a
hierarchical fashion because i don't
think people really have much of an
intuition on how these models behave and
how to reason about them
yes yes that's a very good point so one
thing that we did for example is to
study how the partition of the mapping
evolves as you go through the layers and
what we show is that at each layer you
keep subdividing your current partition
and this is very interesting because
once you know that the if you look at
the binary classification for example
you get that the decision boundary
is basically linear in each region of
the partition and so what this tells you
is that as you add layer what you have
to do is to refine the regions
that still contain more than one class
within them and so this can really bring
insights and maybe opens the door to
building new learning techniques to how
many layers you should stack
which region should they subdivide and
so on and this is really akin to
decision trees and how they build their
partition as well so there is a lot of
work that could be done also to maybe
bridge the two or use one to understand
the other so and it's really geometrical
because it's in the whole field of uh
computational geometry and so on because
we have those hyperplane arrangements
those are spaces intersection of them
hyperplane tessellation
it's also a known
term so it's really geometrical and it
can have a lot of
interesting insights to understand
what's happening
it also provides nice visualization
tools
it's really fascinating it's it's
strained from the would you be
interested in coming back on the show
for a future episode just dedicated to
this topic
yeah sure sure that'd be that should be
amazing um
randall also actually released a paper
called neural decision trees and in the
abstract you said they propose a
synergistic melting of neural networks
and decision trees that they call neural
syndrome
so you know this is something that
you've been thinking about actually from
many angles
yes yes yes and that's very
very synergic to think about one from
the point of view of the other as well
right because if you think of a decision
tree the real limitation of it is that
all you subdivide one region by adding a
node does not really tell you or to
subdivide another region in another part
of the space so you don't have this
let's say communication or
friendly help between the region
subdivision but in a deep net what you
do actually is that if you know how to
subdivide one region then it will
automatically enforce or you subdivide
nearby regions and through this suddenly
you have a mechanism that appear which
is that you don't need samples in each
region to know to subdivide them you
just need sample in some of the regions
and then it will get you on how to
subdivide the regions of the space
without samples and that's something
that is extremely strong when you go to
high dimensional settings because you
cannot have samples in all parts of the
space by definition so i think this is
extremely nice to have both point of
view because then you can try to use the
strength of one to maybe improve the
other so
that's really interesting to me
i want to ask you this question that we
ask a lot of our guests because it's
just at least something that's of kind
of profound interest to me is that
there is this apparent dichotomy between
continuous
and discrete you know it's like it's
like the human brain
is at the most lowest possible level in
analog kind of continuous
system and yet it evolved all these sort
of discrete
almost computations on top of it like
pulses that either fire or don't fire
like that type of thing and in the in
the learning world or let's say really
in the computation world
we have the fact that you know i can
write a very short piece of symbolic
code discrete code
that uh that can go and calculate the
nth digit of pi or something like that
but it's almost impossible to train or
it is currently impossible to train any
neural network of fixed depth
to to do the same thing and so we had
this this weird you know
different regimes we had the discrete
kind of um logic reasoning type world
and then we had the continuous
differentiable
um type of world
do you view those as i mean are they
fundamentally
different regimes and and we're always
going to have hybrid systems that kind
of comb combine both types of
reasoning or is it possible to just say
project
that discrete computation fully into an
analog
type space if you just have enough you
know parameters or something
yeah i think uh so i think it really
depends on the resources that you have
right because uh to me at least it seems
that the hybrid system might be the most
efficient we can
easily let's say cluster different
settings
into groups and then and for this you
can just have a discrete
settings and then within each group
discretization is not good enough
anymore i need to go into the the
continuous regime
so i think it will depend on the
application you have at the end or
how efficient you want to be at doing it
either energy-wise or
anything else so um okay i i i think
it's not
not clear if one should dominate the
other necessarily like for example in
the
if you go back to the spline setting of
a deep net
you have a discrete setting which is
basically your partition which
which region you are in
and then within that region you have a
linear transformation of the mapping
which is basically continuous and both
interact if you adapt one the other one
change and so on and i think having this
type of hybrid systems and where somehow
learning through the continuous part
adapts the discrete part is what is
extremely powerful and that's i think
one extremely
beautiful property of current networks
is that
they do automatically this
adaptive training of their discrete path
through training of their continuous
parameters
and that's why they are so so efficient
like if you think of pure approximation
theory and you have an adaptive spline
in 1d that's why you have the best
convergence rate basically so i think
you really need both systems to interact
if they don't interact then i think it's
really easy to become suboptimal and
in an interesting region because we we
put a similar question to lacoon and he
was kind of saying that um in an ideal
world we would have a discrete system as
well humans are really bad at playing
chess because we don't have that
discrete system built in but the the
problem i think people like lacoon have
with these discrete systems is typically
they're they're symbolic and they're
statically coded you could start talking
about getting into a discrete program
search and you could even guide that
program search based on some deep
learning model but
i don't think to keith's point i don't
think it's really possible to do that
well inside the continuous domain
because if the problem even was
learnable with stochastic gradient
descent the representation would be
glitchy right it just wouldn't it
wouldn't work
yeah i think it depends a lot too on uh
what
are you trying to achieve with with the
model you build if you just try to be as
close as possible to let's say what the
human brain is doing
then you might impose yourself to some
restriction on
do you want it to be discrete or not or
if you just want to have a model that
you can deploy on a task and it can
solve the task as best as you want
so i think yeah depending on what is
your goal and what are you trying to
imitate with the model would
change or you answer that as well right
but what if their goal was task
acquisition efficiency so it's like i
don't know what the task is yet
yeah i think that
like again to me a hybrid system
where you have interaction between both
parts
intuitively will be the most efficient
but yeah it
might not be true for all settings so
when i was looking at figure three uh
both tim and i were interested in the
fact that if you look at the mnist data
which to a human being is kind of a
simpler
data set you know one two three we know
how to do that type of thing
uh
that uh as you increase dimensionality
it
much more rapidly becomes extrapolation
versus imagenet which seems to kind of
more slowly
transition from interpolation to image
extrapolation and what i'm wondering is
the the intuition i got from that and i
wonder if this is completely wrong or
it's correct is that
for machine learning there's a sense in
which mnist is actually a harder problem
because it has to look at kind of global
relationships like it has to try and say
well
there's a circle over here that's kind
of oriented with respect to a line
that's kind of further away and so it's
harder for dude for it to do that
whereas we know that with like imagenet
very frequently ml sort of devolves to
looking at these micro texture like you
know well everything that has this shade
of yellow is a school bus you know type
of thing is that an intuition one can
take from that plot or what does it mean
that mnist
decreases so much more quickly yes so
that's actually something that we tried
to clarify with the figure that comes
after this one
basically the thing that you really need
to be careful about and keep in mind is
that if you look at for example a 16 by
16 patch for mnist you have basically
maybe most of the information you need
to solve the task and you have a lot of
texture about your digit etc if you look
at imagenet and you take a 16 by 16
patch you have basically no information
about the class it's extremely small
patch it's almost constant across the
special dimensions right
it's it's basically a very small
percentage of your full image so that's
why mnis goes
much more quickly to extrapolation
regime for a fixed dimensionality in
pixel space because the information you
have in that amount of dimensions is
greater than for the imaginary case and
this is only because
it's already much more than sampled
right if we are looking at mnist but
with a 224 by 224 special dimension and
we look at the fixed dimensionality then
you will not have this difference
anymore and it might even reverse so the
really important thing to keep in mind
is that even though it's the same
dimension for both it does not represent
the same
proportion of image that is present
within that patch and that's why you
have those differences in uh that's
mostly why you have those differences in
uh in those curves it's funny because we
had the opposite intuition and um so in
the following um uh figure sorry figure
four um you're showing then on mnist
that more of the variance is explained
with fewer of the principal components
on mnist and as you say that that's just
because it's um those those pixels on
mnist are more salient for the problems
could i mean just so just to understand
because we were debating this a little
bit could you just give us your
articulation of figure four
uh yes sure so basically uh what we're
looking so what we are looking for the
increasing dimensionality for the three
data set
is uh we pick a number of dimension in
the spatial space so we do this by
extracting a patch let's say and then
what we do is that we extract of course
the same patch for all the samples
and then we are looking at the
proportion of the test set patches that
are in interpolation regime and we
report this
now for the pca plot what we do is
basically we look at once you extract
this patch how many principal components
you need to explain to perfectly
reconstruct those patches or you could
say to explain the variance in those
patches
and this gives a direct relationship
because it shows how concentrated you
are on lower dimensional manifolds a
fine one of course that learns through
the principal components and it means
that if you can encode much more
information with much less principal
components then you lie on a lower
dimensional affine manifold
and this coupled with figure 1 shows
that basically it's much easier to be in
interpolation regime so the whole point
of using this pca plot was to show
all good low dimensional f5 manifold
represents the current extracted patches
and then to use this as a way to justify
the extrapolation regime curve that we
see
so so because again in the pcr regime
it's a linear manifold so if
only two components for example
perfectly describe all your patches then
you will need very few training samples
to be in the interpolation regime
okay that makes sense and then the
staircase effect on the smooth subsample
row is a function of the size of the
gaussian filter you use to smooth it
yeah so the staircase occurs uh
basically whenever the number of
dimensions increase and we get a new
bigger patch
to get it
because there are different ways there
is different ways to get it right
one would be to always extract the
center patch and remove some dimensions
if you don't have exact number of
dimensions that you can represent with a
squared patch
another thing you could do is to first
smooth sub sample and then remove the
dimensions so there is different
variants on how to extract those patches
we try to show two different ones to
show that the results do not really
depend on how you do this process but
yeah you will have some little uh
different artifacts like this it does
not change the overall trend but yeah it
can change the small trends when you
jump from one dimension to another
but well let me ask you a question here
about uh figure four uh again about the
intuition that we had on leaving aside
interpolation
and extrapolation for the moment
uh it seems that mnist
for for a given amount of variance
explained and for for a given
dimensionality
mnist requires more principal components
for a given number of dimensions
because so if we fix the dimension and
we fix the percent variance explain
mnist requires more principal components
than imagenet
that seems to me to tell me that that
mnist is a more difficult problem that's
not true uh i think it's a bit so for a
specific number of dimensions you could
argue that but the thing you have to
recall is that
because mnist images are much smaller in
spatial dimensions
if you have a 16 by 16 patch you have
basically the world mnist data set let's
say and so just having a few principal
components is not enough to really
reconstruct the world amnest data set
now an imaginative a 16 by 16 patch is
almost a constant texture right you have
a few different colors but you don't
have a lot of variation
it's basically a con through the spatial
dimensions is basically constant and
what this means is that with only three
or four principal components basically
one for each color channel you can
perfectly reconstruct all those 16 by 16
patches
so to really get to the conclusions you
are saying what you will have to do
first is to either don't sample imagenet
to be 28 by 28 or upsample amnese to be
224 by 224 and if you have some
if you do that
then basically i think you will have the
roughly same evolution of the
interpolation regime because the 16 by
16 patch on this extra
up-sampled
mnist image will be either completely
black or completely white and in this
case you will still need a few principal
components so this is also something
very interesting right because
it shows that maybe for the task at end
you might not need
to have such a high resolution image you
might not sample but because when you
don't sample you basically
keep those in crucial information you
don't necessarily go faster to
interpolation regime so this is uh
another point
it's really tricky you should think of
it as how much of the image do i encode
given that number of dimensions and then
given that this plot might make
easier to to understand
sixteen by six
makes total sense yeah exactly so 16 by
16 on mnist is maybe almost 60 70
percent of the image while 16 by 16 on
image net is maybe maybe five percent of
the image and that's why you have those
uh different regimes that appear
incredible
uh randall thank you so much for joining
us this evening
sure thanks
so we just spoke with randall what was
your take on that key
absolutely brilliant it was a
true pleasure to speak with him uh it
cleared up for me it cleared up a lot of
thoughts and issues um i was having with
this paper uh so for example
you know right up front what he says is
my purpose behind this paper
uh is to show that even though the
intuition that people have of
interpolation like the intuition that we
have of interpolation
is good
the mathematical definition that we have
of interpolation is not useful
um in high dimension uh what i thought
was interesting too is when we asked
about well what about the manifold
concept you know why why isn't that sort
of the the definition of of
interpolation and he brought up a really
strong argument there is he said well
let's just take the simple case of
suppose suppose the problem you're
trying to solve just is linear you know
like it just everything is a linear
linear data set linear problem we're
trying to solve like even in that case
this linear case
in high enough dimension
interpolation doesn't work and there
your manifold is just literally a convex
hull
you know and so
sure you can have kind of a non-linear
transformation and a non-linear shape
and whatever you're still hit by
this curse of dimensionality and
he um you know he brought up the point
that like you know of course if your
problem compresses down
enough to where only a small number of
of transformed dimensions right latent
space dimensions matter
and everything then you can be said that
you're
you're interpolating you know because
we're not really hit by that curse of
dimensionality because we stripped away
all the dimensionality down to these
dimensions we've gotten lucky our
problem space our data samples et cetera
allowed us to do that
okay but that's not going to be all
problems like some problems may just
intrinsically have
high dimensionality
of interpolation that's not useful so we
need to do something better we need to
we need to come up with
a distrib or a definition of
interpolation that maintains the
intuitive notion that we have of
interpolation
but that continues to work
in high dimension
and you know and he made a very you know
very interesting kind of end goal here
which is like if we can get a definition
of interpolation
didn't be approaching this concept of
generalization
you know that's
that's what we're trying to achieve
really
and what do you think his take on
generalization is then well he made you
made a comment that you know on the one
hand you could just ridiculously specify
the space and make it trivially
separable but then you lose
generalization
well yeah and i think
i mean because because we did ask uh
or you ask you know you put the question
what if what you're what if the problem
you're trying to solve is the ability to
solve novel problems like
you know what happens then of course
that was in the context of our
discussion about hybrid systems where
you're combining the continuous with
with discrete and they're able to uh
ping pong and kind of modify each other
and i think uh
what we got from him there and and
consistently really throughout
throughout our discussion
and what's interesting is this this
totally aligns actually with um
francois chalet as well which is that
this all these questions like a lot of
these very difficult questions that
we're asking
are problem specific and there is no
we don't currently have some one size
fits all set of concepts
that fits well for it for every every
problem space you know it's very task
specific very problem specific
you know data specific
so i think that's an area where we gotta
dive deeper with him um but i didn't
hear anything definitive
you know today it's a wrap
we just interviewed the godfather of
deep learning how's that possible i
think we can just quit now we might as
well just shut the channel down
yeah
i mean obviously after we've published
it
that's the singularity
so what's your take folks
i would have i would i think i think
this um
but we also interrupted him a little bit
maybe the question was i would have
loved for him to to be more a bit on
like you know where's the actual
disagreement right because a lot of
times you know when we when we put put
you know questions to him like okay
other people say this he was like oh
yeah i agree right um and this seems it
seems to be a general sentiment that's
also when we talk to other people about
you know perceived disagreements they're
always very
you know being being being good being
academics being also friends probably
with a lot of people you always like
yeah you know they have their they have
good point you know we we essentially
agree
on all the
on all the things right but then i i
sort of want to know
where actually do people disagree right
if it's
if it's uh
you know in
and that that
that is
a little bit i mean i i obviously have a
feeling but it's still a little bit
elusive and and um
if
people disagree on on the actual
technical nature or more on the
philosophical end of what do what does
something mean
um i definitely think there is from from
hearing now and i think
from his answer to that question um i
could hear a little bit in that
um he seems to be more optimistic
on what these learning systems can do
than maybe other people are right
because some people right seem to have
really kind of a hard stop on like this
will never be possible with like a
learning system
whereas it seemed it seemed uh it seemed
uh
that
he had sort of a more optimistic outlook
and said of course they can't do it now
right however um you know we work on it
we modify them you know we're we're
figuring out how do we need to build
these systems such that you know a
learning system can conceivably you know
do many of the things that people would
call
a kind of reasoning and i i think that's
why he went into you know let me give
you an example of reasoning
uh to sort of show look here you know
here is here is an example of a
reasoning that neural networks already
do
and that means that something like
reasoning
in general isn't too far away
and that's ultimately where
the disagreement might be with other
people i mean i think that's that was my
take on his answer to our first question
like the um you know why'd you write
this paper
is i think and i maybe i gotta go back
and watch this but i think essentially
what he was saying is
you know
sometimes people
they have some definition in their mind
whatever it is of interpolation and
extrapolation
and they come up with kind of an
argument to say see the this this
machine learning is doing
interpolation and in a binary sense it
can't do
extrapolation and so therefore there's
this entire class of things
you know that it's not capable of doing
and i think that's what his objection
was which is look like
this is not a useful distinction to say
between
um
you know it's not a useful distinction
to draw between quote-unquote
interpolation
and extrapolation like here's an example
of a definition right that's a
relatively standard definition of
interpolation and if we apply this
interpolation to
theoretically what machine learning is
doing and empirically to what machine
learning is doing it's always
extrapolating so i think that's what
he's objecting to is just like look
don't come to some
strong conclusion about what
machine learning neural networks i'm not
sure what the right way to phrase things
is now
what it's capable of doing like we just
need to do more work to expand its
capabilities you know folks like gary
marcus making this case of we need
discrete models because they can
abstract broadly they give a couple of
examples you know binary encoding for
numbers and there's one example with can
you have a model that reverses the bits
or i think there is another example in
his algebraic mind which was about can
you generalize from the even numbers to
the odd numbers and you can't do that
and the reason you can't do it is the
new examples are completely outside of
the training space of the input data and
probably that problem is not
interpretive or it's it's not
differentiable yeah i mean walid saba
says the same thing he says in language
processing in particular like in
language understanding in order to have
broad generalization you need to have
abstract rules so for example being able
to generalize from mary loves john to
mary loves jane they make the argument
that with a statistical approach that
just wouldn't be possible well i think
so i think and this just my opinion but
i think his answer
to my digits of pie question
um kind of shed some light on what his
position is on this which is that it's
too early
theoretically and scientifically for us
to make that that determination like
because he said look okay people have
only been able to calculate digits of pi
you know like within the last hundred
years or whatever i'm not talking like
we're not there yet i'm not talking
about
that class of problems i'm talking about
these prime numbers as well right so i'm
talking about these things like a cat
jumping up here and so some of these
examples that gary marcus may bring up
may fall into that even though they seem
simple okay they seem deceptively simple
they may still fall in the bucket of
these kind of much more towards the
discrete spectrum of of capabilities
which we can't currently do with with
our methods and of machine learning but
we're going to continue and continue to
get closer to that that end of the
spectrum um and so it's and so it's it's
premature to say that
like
machine learning and again whatever you
can see that to be neural networks
whatever will never be able to get there
like can he and yan is optimistic that
we'll be able to get there i'm not as
optimistic i think there is a very
there's just a qualitative
difference between
you know
structural topological discrete
reasoning and continuous differentiable
reasoning and i don't know how we're
ever gonna get that gap bridged he
brought up some some methods
um to think about but
right but the key question is whether
it's possible at all
and
there was an article by a guy called
andrew yee i think and it really annoyed
yan lcoon and he said look people are
still making the argument that neural
networks interpolate and in that um
article he was basically saying well
neural networks are a little bit like a
taylor series approximation you take a
function and you just kind of
approximate it you know inside a certain
range and then it goes haywire outside
of the range and francois relay came on
the podcast and he said look you know
it's a little bit like in fourier
analysis when you try and you you kind
of like um you take these little signs
and cosines and you fit it to a discrete
function and it's glitchy right and um
actually if you look at harmonic
analysis this is what um
joann bruner said on the show on the
geometric show he said that while a
neural network even the universal
function approximation theorem is it's
all about stacking these basis functions
together right to kind of approximate
some target function well if that's all
neural networks do how could they
possibly generalize
look i i don't want to use a word like
generalized i don't know that
what i would say is this which is that
no matter how discrete an appearance
the human brain is you know all the
signals that neurons generate receive
whatever
you know at the end of the day
are
continuous functions i mean they're you
know a charge that has a continuous
function
now somehow or another like the brain
and its structure
does take that continuous analog
i should have said analog you know
probably better word but it takes that
analog computational environment and
produces
digital reasoning so i don't think it's
beyond like i just don't see how
anyone could reach the conclusion that
it will be impossible like to do
discrete reasoning with with neural
networks i think it's just a question of
like for me i think it's more of a
question is that the efficient way to do
it like you know if you fast forward 2
000 years from now when people have
figured out all these problems and we
have like you know ais walking around
killing us or working for us whatever
the
thing may be you know
are they going to be using a neural
network for everything or is it going to
be a neural network with you know some
classic digital compute components with
some other stuff like a hybrid kind of
structural system
that does things i think is more
what i'm asking
um yeah like lacon hint they of course
that that's what i was going to say they
have like nature on their side in that
in no matter how much we cut open the
human brain we don't find like a
discrete computer in there like of
course the individual neural spikes are
discrete like there's either charge or
no charge but then there's like
continuous release of neurotransmitter
so i agree like the brain is like a very
continuous
distributed machine and there's no
no
there's no discrete thing in there
there's no part of the brain where it's
like look one
one
brain brainy packety he's he's he said
that and and there is a level which
that's true which is
there's a spike train and you know we
can kind of recognize a spike because
it's a maximum in this
analog dimension but my point is
it's still an underlying analog
dimension and so i don't see why in
principle you couldn't build
a neural network that
you know has like these kind of
continuous values but still
ends up with something that that's that
synthesizes a a discrete
you know decision
sure but wouldn't it be glitchy and it
still wouldn't extrapolate
i have no idea like what uh you know i
just don't know i think i think this
kind of point is we're too early on to
to reach these
conclusions that it cannot be done i i
do sort of feel that it's just not the
efficient way to do it that that you
know we're going to end up with a case
where
we're going to have systems that have
analog continuous chunks
that are neural networks or whatever and
we're also going to overlay that with
uh with digital computation that's
implemented by the you know typical kind
of digital computer that's going to be
these hybrid systems working together
just like you brought up with hey look
you know
alpha alpha zero alphago all those
things are can be viewed in the same
kind of hybrid way right
but that's exactly i mean
you said this is what you said and also
what when he when he said like
so first when he said you know we're far
away from that
with the digits of pi and so on but also
when he said you know humans are
actually pretty bad at chess or at
discrete exploration in general
and that is
that's how humans do it right humans
build discrete reasoning
on top of this sort of neural
continuous function and it's actually
really hard like to do discrete
reasoning in your head it's you can do
it slowly and you have to do it
deliberately with attention if you do
like multiplication of five digit number
in your head right this is not a this is
not a oh my god feeling this is like you
you like you sit there and you you have
to like keep all this stuff
we built children's toys like that that
for like 20 cents that multiply ten
digit numbers easily right so
i like yeah i think this is we teach
both ways we teach them hash table
lookup like memorize you know yeah all
the numbers from one to a hundred
multiplied or something and then we
teach them an algorithm you know we
teach them the screen
thing and we teach them hash table
lookup
and and this is built on so so if you i
think that if you build if you build
this discrete reasoning you can probably
build it on top of these
models right but
yes is it the most efficient way to do
it
maybe
maybe not right but then again if you do
it
if you manage to do it and train it you
seem at least from at least from from
the perspective of humans you seem to
have something insanely powerful right
because you know if you just have a
discrete algorithm you have the
algorithm but if you have a discrete if
you've actually managed to train a
discrete algorithm on top of this
continuous function
it will be able to sort of learn in the
same continuous way that you know a
neural network learns but you know it
will be sort of be able to self-modify
its discrete algorithm and that
yeah i think
you know
i i i agree i'd also be in the maybe
longer term future positive that that
might be possible but i think that's
because i said to him and do you think
alphago is a good thing do you think
it's a good thing to have um a kind of
um discreet search which is guided by a
neural network and he didn't like it and
i assume he didn't like it for the
reason you just said yannick which is
that the discrete part of it is
hard-coded and it's been told to do a
specific task it's not learning i think
lacoon would rather have something which
is entirely differentiable
right so because
lacoon wants learning end-to-end in in a
in a neural network
right yeah and and also it's almost like
he was saying before well um
humans can't do discrete reasoning so it
would actually be a more sophisticated
form of intelligence if we had discrete
reasoning but do we necessarily even
want that in our models or is it just
the fact that he wants it in the models
but he wants it to be differentiable and
learnable as part of the main model
i think so because that's where he got
with the um you know the critic uh actor
critic type models i think if people
nowadays talk about differentiable they
always talk about um sort of they always
talk about like single shot feet forward
like you know i i input something into
the machine and out comes a prediction
whereas he also makes a lot of arguments
for you know this um
uh energy minimization which which means
that essentially at test time at
inference time i do a minimization
algorithm and you know when he when he
talked about reasoning he was mentioning
that
as an example as essentially saying look
i have my trained neural network and now
at inference time i actually still
perform an algorithm on top of that
right to minimize some energy function
given my trained model of the world
let's say so
i i think
we might be able to make that more
learned by also
learning
the algorithm that we do at inference
time but i don't necessarily i don't
necessarily think that he he's talking
about you know we need
like we need to end to end learn like a
machine where you simply input something
and then out pops through forward prop
output pops announcements all of these
things are just reasoning by the back
door
because even with that as i understand
that that's just the way of hacking the
the value the advantage function right
you know with some i mean i'm not an
expert in possibly anybody but i think
that's what it is um the same thing with
the energy minimization yeah i kind of
agree with you there but the energy
minimization has this particular thing
of of of this idea which i think today
is underexplored of to actually do
something at inference time
like to not just forward prop and and
that i feel it's i feel it's under
underexplored
uh nowadays no i i agree with you there
too but i think what kind of sometimes i
feel like this is feature creep in a
sense it's like
you know we have neural networks and we
know what deep learning is and and some
people now want that to be redefined
it's just a general purpose research
paradigm that includes all possible
things that we can do with uh you know
uh
machines or chemicals it's like
what use is that like what uses it
defining you know
all types of computation as as
differentiable computation like we lose
some ability to talk about these and in
sort of a the same way that was kind of
like was saying you know nobody i mean
look
allowing for a variable number of layers
in a neural network
that's discrete computation right that's
not differentiable training nobody knows
how to train
in like an arbitrarily unbounded number
of layers in some differentiable way
right
but there's the neural neural ode stuff
well all those types of things run into
big training problems like things become
really hard to train when you have these
types of yeah of um essentially discrete
you know uh um transitions right or
combinatorial kinds of
kinds of transitions um
and this is classic stuff i mean this is
really classic stuff it's like even if
you try to do mixed integer
um optimization right so you have a
problem that has some combination of
integer variables discrete variables and
some combination of continuous variables
there's all kinds of hacks to try to do
that in differentiable ways
they don't in general arrive at the
optimal
discrete
solution like you you do some continuous
stuff and then at the end you kind of
discretize it in one way or another and
you wind up with a solution that's kind
of approximately correct
but you're not guaranteed that you're
going to find the one that's actually
correct
if you discreetly combinatorially
examine that that space right
can we finish by talking about a couple
of things so first of all there's table
one
and the structure of the latent table
one is the biggest
um the biggest argument against the most
prevalent argument against this paper
sorry for the like triple negative but
you know when when you know when the
paper starts out by saying you know we
build a convex hall of the training data
if your point is not in the convex hull
you know not interpolating and then
people go wait wait wait but you're
talking about the input space of data
you're talking about the pixel space and
you know for sure we're not talking
about the pixel space because you know
the neural network is you know the data
manifold and
but we're talking about you know if you
go to the last layer to the latent space
before the classification it's just a
linear clash you know there in that
space we're talking about like
interpolation right there is where the
neural networks interpolate and this
experiment clearly shows like
okay it might be a rigid definition of
interpolation but it clearly shows like
no even in that space on a trained
resnet uh there is no
like no interpolation going on as soon
as you pick like 30 dimensions or more
it's all outside of the convex hall of
training right but but this this this
gets to the punchline right because
keith was going to ask a really cool
question which is like well imagine it
was a very small latent and it was
interpolating and then what if you up
projected it like to 102 four dimensions
and that you know would that suddenly
now be extrapolating right so we almost
need to have an information theoretical
theoretical way of looking at this but
um anyway like my intuition is that deep
learning models encode the most high
frequency information into the latent
space right and you know this
information would be encoded in a
minimally distributed way to denoise the
predictive task which is to say right
you know there's a few dimensions of the
latent you know which should be encoding
the actual things that that you've
trained it on so my intuition is
actually most of the dimensions of the
latent are kind of just encoding low
frequency information so you can discard
them right and i know you said the other
day well well maybe the whole point of
neural networks is there are distributed
representations so maybe they are
distributed over all of the layers over
all of the dimensions in the latent i
mean i would i would actually argue not
that neural networks are
uh putting the data in a minimally
distributed way but in like a maximally
like
i think
just just my intuition is that a neural
if if i were a neural network and i had
all of these dimensions at my disposal i
would encode lots of information
redundantly if it like if it were too
much space i would like encode the same
information
pretty much redundantly in many of the
dimensions uh that i could but that's
noisy right so you're taking a soft max
and if you're noisily aggregating over
all of those features that you don't
want to do that
yeah but still if i have back prop right
then the back prop path goes through
each of the dimensions so for each of
the dimensions i'm asking myself how can
i change this one to make my prediction
even better right
it doesn't matter if over there one of
the dimensions is already doing the
classification for me right the back
prop the nature of back prop means that
you know i'm going to every single
dimension independently and deciding how
can i change this one to make it even
better so that's why i think lots of
information if the latent is too big
lots of information will be encoded but
that's the key right there is if the
latent is too big and so this is where
all the pruning literature comes into
which is that the majority of the time
people are running neural networks in
situations where the latent space is too
big
like they're just you know we just flat
out have far too many you know
far too large of a latent space and so
even though it may be encoded you know
densely there like it may be putting all
kind of little bits of extra information
it's probably only adding little plus or
minus you know 0.1 percent type type
things to the accuracy whereas and so
since it is only adding these little
kind of very tiny values there right
the only meaningful way to talk about
interpolation or extrapolation because
you've only got little bits of stuff
you're using on that entire dimension
that you've added there is really more
just are you interpolating on the the
most salient dimensions
you know which is again back to my
question about why are we
you know
why are we concerned with whether or not
every single dimension
falls within within the sample range
yeah exactly but there's there's a few
things there i mean it's really good
that you bring up sparsity i think
that's that's fantastic that you brought
that in because as you say
most of that information is redundant
but then what yannick was saying was
interesting
does distributing all that information
rather that because my intuition is it
increases noise but actually i think
yannick's saying it increases precision
but in a very tiny tiny like it's a tiny
tiny contribution so let let's suppose
the latent space is not too large right
like if the latent space is not too
large in other words it's let's say it's
just barely big enough
to to to classify your images and let's
suppose you're doing multi-class so
we've got 10 10 10 classes
you know and we just barely got enough
latent space for it
my intuition would tell me that if those
classes are
somewhat different from one another like
it's not reclassifying
brown dogs from white dogs from like
every other you know simple kind of dog
but they're different from each other
and it's not easy to determine
you know which is which that what would
and just to guess is that probably what
would happen is you would find that you
know these five bits
are kind of the ones that tell you
whether something is a dog and these
seven bits tell you if it's a duck and
these four bits tell you if it's a gun
and these five bits tell you if it's an
image of the sky like i would guess that
it would
end up encoding it that way since they
don't have a lot in common
you can't really you can't really use
entanglement like too much except for a
few dimensions there might be some
overlaps but
yeah i think what what people what
people mean a little bit is when they
when they start going down the uh
interpolation road is that
you we've played with gpt-3 as well
right and then you you you do something
with it you enter something and
in some places you're like i see how you
did that right you're like you you just
took that that newspaper article and you
just kind of replaced some stuff in it
right like you you sort of
whereas if you were to to talk to like a
human you you'd sort of
like that stuff wouldn't happen as much
even and of course there's there's the
argument i think people that say well
it's just interpolating or it might also
be you know it's just sort of
repeating the stuff in the training data
i think what they what i'd like to see
is more like
uh the pattern that these
models extract aren't sufficiently high
level
uh for for them right and i think the
entire discussion is
can we get
to
arbitrary
high abstractive levels of
pattern recognition
with such models if we engineer them
train them in the correct way or is
there is there i guess some fundamental
limitation
uh to that and and yeah as as we said
that the answer the answer might be
might be quite far off as as for the
number of you know latent dimensions and
so on i i mean i agree
with keith i think
having a big latent space and
also having big weights and so on is
might be um more of a of a necessity for
training
uh than it really is for for encoding
like it appears to help if we have lots
of weights to train such that sort of we
get to combinatorically try out uh
combinations of weights only few of
which might ultimately end up being
important right that's kind of a lottery
hypothesis sort of way of of going down
so yeah i agree you know most of most of
the information ultimately might be
only contributing a little bit
right but
my my hint my intuition would me be that
you know this is kind of because it's
kind of redundant information right
because it's like you know i'm i'm
encoding this over here i'm also
encoding it in like a tiny little
different way over here um or or some
add-on or some uncertainty or some one
training sample is a bit different so
i'm going to put that right here
yeah that's fascinating what he said
about franco's work though i never
really heard you articulate it like that
but it's actually kind of like a search
problem rather than a learning problem
what you're doing is you're giving it
all of the possible you know you give a
random initialization on a densely
connected network and you're saying you
know just go and find the ones that work
rather than create it from first
principle yeah that's why
initializations are so important right
is is because you sort of you sort of
try
like your initialization essentially is
is your your your uh your buffet
for sgd to like choose a good one from
to then go ahead and refine
but how much refining is it is it more
is it more finding things that already
work versus refining yeah it's it's it's
well same but what it is not is sort of
learning from scratch
that that's what like people like we
cannot you cannot initialize a neural
network from zeros and then have it have
it learn well at least not today maybe
that's gonna come in in some form but
initialization is actually pretty
important pretty crazy and that's crazy
and that's yeah that's like one hint
that
you know we're we're not essentially
we're never essentially training from
scratch we're we're we're sort of
training we're sort of giving the choice
of many combinations of good weights or
of semi-good weights and and it has to
pick sort of the good ones to continue
yeah exactly it's already pre-trained
you just don't know which
ah yeah i mean the argument that a
little bit of the argument against that
is in in sort of the evolutionary
approach where you say you know you can
make the argument you know humans have
sort of developed these abilities to
reason to recognize super high level
patterns while only having a continuous
brain
um
but then the other
side of this is
yeah but it's not like a single human
that has achieved that right it's not
like one single learning system that has
achieved that but it's actually like
this evolutionary system which is in
essence a massively distributed
combinatorical
trial and error search right and that is
that is not a
learning system so to say as we imagine
it today it
at the end you end up with a learning
result but
uh the the evolutionary algorithm is way
different than we imagined learning it's
not even all it's not even all humans
that have learned it it's it's all
you know individuals of all tens of
millions of species that have ever lived
on earth that have that have learned
exactly right which is
pretty much like like the lottery ticket
hypothesis let's just let's just
randomly train
crap tons of uh you know
weights and and then slowly prune them
and see what happens
right brilliant well gentlemen it's been
an absolute pleasure
i guess i guess we'll make this a
christmas special i mean it is pretty
special
all right let's be honest so um yeah
this is gonna work
yeah
nice meeting you
indeed but um thanks for bearing with us
folks we have had a couple of months off
i've had a bit of a break and you know
the guys had a bit of a break so yeah
we're back
good to see you all again
peace out